Lull.
Was ist hier los?
Hab grad gesehen, in der Viewerliste
Campen schon die ersten Leute
auf dem Channel
Campen ihr seid entlarvt
Lull
ein bisschen technisch zeug kaufen vor allem muss ich mir haben wir was neues
haben wir was neues bestellt bei unity media erst erst mal warten erst mal
warten bis twitch sich eingekriegt hat und gesagt hat dass der streben und ist
ein bin aber da den impuls future und in phoenix underscore ganz wichtig
feifett feifett usernamen habe gerade ein kott video gesehen mal wieder mega
nice und klasse dass du wieder videos machst ja ich weiß auch nicht warum ich
auf einmal so motiviert bin ich hatte heute die auswahl ich hatte heute die
auswahl ein video zu machen zu einem comment was man vielleicht uns heute
angucken oder oder mal zwischendurch mal wieder gestreben so also ich muss ja
ab und zu mal ab und zu mal streben so ist der track ja schon fertig nie da ist
noch nicht ganz fertig aber ich habe schon ein paar neue da hat er hat jetzt
email email tracking kann ich nachher mal zeigen den track so erinnere mich
bitte noch mal dran ich bin mir sicher dass ich bin vergesslich was so was
angeht genau und ich habe gesagt muss ich mal wieder streben so zwischendurch weil wir haben
neue emotes leute haben neue emotes wir haben jetzt ich zeige ich zeige es euch
mal wir haben wo wohl das haben wir schon die ganze zeit wir haben wo es das ist
wenn mal wieder irgendwas nicht funktioniert wie sollte ja wir haben
kap in hd und ganz wichtig ich bin mittlerweile 35 wir haben wupp old also
wir haben wir haben neue comments am start ein bisschen gedauert bis sie
genehmigt wurden ich mein zwei wochenende switch arbeitet auch nicht
unbedingt immer rund um die uhr ja und wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben
genau ich habe ich mache einfach mit der eine runde streben dazwischen ja es
reicht wenn ich alle zwei tagen video macht wenn überhaupt also weil ich mein
sonst ist je nachdem sonst ist meine motivation wieder vielleicht schneller
schneller weg wenn ich wenn ich gar so sehr über drei oder immer erstmal
langsam übrigens es ist muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen es ist übelst
frustrierend wenn man anfängt auf youtube nach längerer zeit wieder videos
zu machen sage ich aber gleich was zu weil ich habe mir überlegt ich poste ich
poste den streben heute mal auf youtube ich warte jetzt aber erst mal bis
switch die ankündigungen geschickt hat das ist
ja da wird es da wird es ein bisschen voll aber es passt es ist unter der woche
da wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so voll
genau und zwar was ich euch zeigen wollte ich habe ich habe bei unity media ich
habe was neues bestellt wir haben uns ja mal vor einer weile
angeguckt ich habe ja die ganze zeit hatte ich ja telekom plus unity media
parallel weil ich dem einen nicht getraut habe und dem anderen nicht
getraut habe ehrlich zu sein ich trau der ganzen geschichte immer noch nicht aber
ich trau meinem geldbeutel ich habe kein bock zwei internetanschlüsse zu bezahlen
habe keinen bock 140 euro auszugeben im monat wo ich mal überlegen 140 euro für
internet in deutschland nicht so sagt das ist eher und deswegen habe ich die
telekom jetzt gekündigt hat den grund ich will halt den den anbieter der bei
mir die höhere bandbreite liefert bei mir am standort und der alles irgendwie
anbieten kann und unity media kann halt der ganze ganze fernsehkram ich meine ich
brauche nicht aber da gibt es leute die wollen fernseh gucken und ich will halt
40 mbit ab und 400 dauernd ich hätte die auswahl bei der telekom gehabt maximal
250 dauen und dafür 100 ab allerdings wohlgemerkt bräuchte ich dann zusätzlich
immer noch in unity media gedöns für fernsehen oder oder aber ich müsste mir
eine satellitenschuss und hinstellen ist auch nicht so sinnvoll und letztendlich
ist bei unity media gelandet wieder hat die ganze zeit schon den ausschlag der
ausschlaggebende punkt war und ich weiß das ist überall in deutschland
unterschiedlich der ausschlag gegen den punkt der ausschlaggebende punkt ist
gewesen dass die telekom bei mir nicht sonderlich stabil war ich weiß bei den
meisten leuten ist es genau umgedreht bei den meisten leuten ist die telekom
stabiler als unity media aber bei mir ist umgedreht bei mir die telekom übelste
probleme und deswegen gibt es jetzt unity media easy und deswegen muss ich
mir zumindest eine neue fritzbox holen weil die die ich jetzt habe ich habe
aktuell 37 40 ist das glaube ich
glaube ich mal her ja die billigste habe ich die ist halt die hatten nur den 100
mbit port muss ich das mal überlegen im jahr 2018 oder 17 wo ich die gekauft
habe gibt es tatsächlich von AVM noch router wie die sysco fans sagen routers
mit einem mit einem 100 mbit port
hyperlul ist das geil warum sowas gibt ich dass ibaro
also auf jeden fall heute bevor bevor ich das auf youtube poste heute
hallo michael bevor ich das auf youtube poste wir brauchen ein mod wo es
mindestens ein mod da sein wenn kein mod da ist kann ich nicht auf youtube
posten weil man weiß nie so genau was da was da von youtube auftaucht alles das
ist nicht so ganz klar im vorfeld und die 40s f
hat vom mod ja das ist jetzt ist zwar hier zwar q chat allerdings traue ich
da lieber mein mods die schon eine weile dabei sind als dem chat das zu
moderieren
im discord gucken ob da jetzt irgendwie das ibaro oder so am start ist
ist die musik zu laut passt eigentlich denke ich
alle was ich gespamme was hier los übrigens wer ich hab letztens in den
comments gelesen hier die leute haben sich alle alle wahnsinnig gewundert ich
in discord habe also wenn wenn ihr in den discord nicht haben auf den discord
wollt ausrufe zeichnen discord leon gerdes twitch prime pock sehr nice
oh ich habe das ich habe das fenster nicht ausgeblendet
dankeschön das ibaro ist nicht da doch das ibaro ist da ja da ist ja nicht
hat es discord hat es discord gecheckt ja discord hat es kapiert ok immerhin
twitch ach ich habe ja ganz vergesst ich habe sogar extra ein prime prime
sound mic mzr twitch prime nice dankeschön
was ich heute vor habe ich will mal ausbrühen ob das ganze funktioniert
weil nachdem ich jetzt ja ausnahmsweise mal wieder furchtbar aktiv auf youtube
gewesen bin ob die youtube only leute das mit ein pendant keine ahnung aber
das ist nice ich mag ich ich mag mein sinnloses eingeblende
habt ihr übrigens schon mal wo alt ausprobiert als chat als immer oder
ob alt jetzt neu passt zwei monate kalumina 0 1 huge brain jeder weitere
monat subscriber wisst ihr ja bringt noch mehr brain
ich weiß jetzt habe ich hier die secrets revealed aber muss ja auch mal
gesagt werden nach weiter mit deinen videos ja ich hoffe die
motivation verlässt mich nicht
aber ist ja was ich poste das jetzt mal auf youtube mal gucken was passiert
mal gucken was passiert gucken ohne mod im zweifelsfall muss ich entweder gleich
jemanden modden oder das habe ich nicht auf dem zweiten bildschirm jetzt für
ein mist aufgemacht oder ich bann einfach alle die mir auf den sack gehen
das geht natürlich auch und ihr wisst wir gehen menschen prinzipiell auf den
kicks okay achte baro ist da pock also sebaro ich werde jetzt ich werde jetzt
mal auf youtube posten dass ich online bin mit einem streben so und dass wir
uns heute ein bisschen bisschen die youtube comments angucken weil es waren
richtig viele nice gute comments dabei es waren auch viele muss ich jetzt mal
sagen es waren auch die übertriebenen call of duty fanboy kommentare wieder
dabei weiß habe ich gemerkt sonntag upload sonntag 18 uhr 18 uhr 20 oder
wann das angegangen ist gar nicht sieht man das überhaupt von das video
angegangen ist und das irgendwo wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist
sieht man sieht man nicht ist auf jeden fall zu spät weil die leute können
nicht mehr gucken sonntags und montags sind die leute arbeiten sind einfach mal
20 prozent weniger views innerhalb der ersten paar stunden wie auf den anderen
soll ich poste das jetzt mal gucken mal ich bin echt gespannt was passiert
kann man überhaupt twitch kann man überhaupt twitch verlinkung auf youtube
posten ohne ohne dass instant monka tos angesagt ist
probieren wir mal aus machen ich bin nicht der einzige der das macht außerdem
habe ich die letzten vor vor ein zwei jahren habe ich auch als die overwatch
steams gepostet habe ich das ja auch gepost twitch.tv wo bloß bei der way
gibt neue emotes genau
ich habe zu viel text geschrieben da steht dann alles unter mehr anzeigen dass
das sagt beitrag erstellen achtung leute jetzt kommen jetzt kommen die youtube
leute
irgendwie ist die youtube seite ganz schön kaputt in letzter zeit
leider kann ich es euch nicht zeigen da kann ich es euch nicht zeigen mittlerweile
ist es auf youtube wirklich ja monka smoke das ist so kaputt
ursprünglich also vor 2010 also es hat sich über die über die jahre immer
verschlimmert und zwar am anfang war das so du hast du hattest hier oben hast du
dein creator center gehabt auf youtube und das alles drin in box mit chat
nachrichten kommentare monetarisierung für videos video listen alles und
mittlerweile ich weiß ich inwieweit man da reinguckt wenn man keine videos macht
mittlerweile ist es so auf youtube du hast fünf verschiedene du eins wo du
sachen einstellst du hast das kund das neue creator studio beta das steht ganz
fett beta drauf aber du bist standardmäßig drauf geleitet in dem du
noch nicht mal so basic sachen wie playlists machen kannst willst du
playlists machen musst du ins creator studio classic willst du einblendung im
video machen musst du auf den auf den karts editor
willst du sachen editieren im video kriegst du den video edit total wie du
hast fünf verschiedene grüß channel channel bearbeiten geht noch mal im
komplett anderen menü und so was ganz ganz mir ganz ganz mir
phoenix zwei monate dankeschön wollen schwarz auf weiß ist junity media gut
wollen von telekom junity media wechseln es kommt darauf an wo du wohnst ja was
wesentlich wie sieht es denn bei dir aus also ich meine wenn wenn telekom und
junity media ähnliche sachen anbieten würde ich sagen pauschal würde ich die
telekom bevorzugen außer bei mir muss die telekom nicht gebacken kriegen
ordentlich stabil ordentlich stabile sache zu liefern wenn du allerdings bei
einem der beiden anbieter mehr kriegst und der preis für dich angemessen
erscheint dann würde ich auch sagen dem den ich weiß ich schwierig was hast du
denn zur auswahl ja previously das neue creator studios übelst übelst krab ich
weiß gar nicht was ich dabei gedacht haben vor allem dass das youtube
creator studio das steht schon seit einem jahr auf beta seit einem jahr
steht darauf beta und es kommt einfach nicht mehr rein und ich bin denke was
was was machen die da eigentlich aber es ist halt es ist halt youtube oder wie
der master krabber immer sagt youtube ich weiß gar nicht wie man auf die
aussprache kommt aber wenn er karsten das sagt dann ist das so ein killer
tomate
die telekom hat sich geschissen bekommen bei euch drei monate gut trifft man
die telekom bekommt vieles nicht geschissen junity media bekommt auch
vieles nicht geschissen zumindest was ich mir jetzt bestellt habe bei junity
media ist das da to fly das können ganz ehrlich to fly konnte auch
irgendwie der name von einem schlechten hip-hop mensch sein
to fly klingt irgendwie sind so three fly und jetzt kommen jetzt kommen die
leute hier aber an
alle die von youtube am start sind wo ist der minecraft staubsauger also ich bin
mir nicht sicher wie gut das funktioniert ich muss jetzt erstmal
ein usb stick an dem staubsauger zum laufen kriegen dass ich überhaupt was
drauf installieren kann weil der staubsauger ich könnte auch für die
leute die von youtube kommen den könnte ich noch mal mein staubsauger zeigen
zumindest das problem ist ich habe da glaube ich plus 2 gigabyte platz und das
ist ein bisschen schwierig alles auf dem staubsauger was sagt ihr kann man sich
modern warfare vorbestellt ich würde mir aus prinzip nie was vorbestellen
weil muss ich immer mit was hast du davon wenn es vorbestellt oder haben die
irgendwelche super zeigt mal das ubuntu scheißhaus gibt nur nur bunto
staubsauger es gibt kein ubuntu klo das klo ist auch ohne ubuntu schlau genug
was versprichst du dir denn vom vorbestellen
so genau was ich mir jetzt bestellt habe bei unity media ist folgendes ich habe
mir hier to play fly 400 bestellt ich habe mir nur aus dem einzigen grund
toplay bestellt weil es billiger ist als als einfach nur internet mit kabel
anschluss ja es auch nicht schnelleres gibt und man muss hier ganz genau gucken
man muss hier nämlich ganz genau gucken weil das da ist das wichtige das muss
man dazu bestellen sonst ist es crap wenn man nicht da wenn man das nicht
dabei bestellt und damit bekommt man 400 mbit down und mit power upload für 299
euro im monat mehr kriegt man 40 mbit upload friseur auch auf twitch ja macht
mal ausrufezeichen frisi er heißt ja nicht mal friseur er heißt ja er ist ja
frisi mittlerweile oder der high society fris meister das ist die baro
genau ausrufezeichen frisi ist der bot kaputt ist der nightbot kaputt ne der
nightbot ist da ausrufezeichen fahmian haben wir nicht ausrufezeichen frisi
drin
nur ja also das muss ich mal schauen und deswegen muss ich mir eine neue fris box
bestellen die alte muss ich leider wegschmeißen
ist ja nicht was es für einen akt war das ding am laufen zu kriegen hinter dem
unity media router
moin ich muss mein ich muss mein ich muss meinen chat logger anmachen wenn ich
mein chat logger nicht anmache über sehe tausende fragen jetzt wieder
ein leute muss ich muss den chat den chat logger einschalten
keylogger ist an also jetzt im chat schreibt jetzt ausfüllen sein passwort
warum nicht mario jetzt ausfüllen sein passwort im chat postet hat gelitten
oh schon wieder abgelaufen dachte dachte ich habe erst wie nennen wir es denn ich
habe erst die evaluierungszeit neu evaluiert
er kommt das passwort von euch das glaube ich euch nicht das ist zu komplex
ja und die meisten haben wahrscheinlich passwörter 123456 ja auch wer hier im
stream öfters dabei wo ich irgendwelche accounts irgendwelche fake accounts
angelegt habe halt bestes passwort 123456
ist es überhaupt das richtige was ich hier
meint ist das falsche was ich gestartet habe ich kacke nur ja zumindest ich
weiß nicht genau welche kabel fritzbox ich mir holen soll ich brauche
nämlich ich starte das mal nebenbei übrigens will ich auf deutsch haben nicht
auf englisch
ich hätte mein passwort ja 123456 du bist aber ein guter du bist aber in
guter gesellschaft
moment habe ich habe ich wieder das falsche geöffnet bin so dämlich
open kann man nicht konnte man nicht in last projects öffnen oder sowas
was machst denn ich mache mein chat log an habe ich den denn sag mal wo habe
ich mein chat logger und wo ist mein wo ist mein chat logger hin ich jetzt total
beknackt wo ist mein chat logger
wo habe ich mein chat logger
das ist ja nicht monka smoke ja
das ist nicht mein chat logger habe ich mein chat logger
das ding wie hieß das wie hieß das noch mal wie habe ich denn noch mal geland
pepega bord ja wo wo habe ich den denn hin
doch das hier na klar ist doch das hier manchmal
manchmal bin ich echt schwer vom begrüß doch das richtige gewesen was ich
gestartet habe ja ganz viel ja weil ich habe den chat logger gebastelt oder wir
haben besser gesagt im im stream den chat logger gebastelt für für twitch dass
ich die fragen und zeug nicht über sehe
was macht die paket liefere ab kommt dazu noch ab so ja die machen wir ich
hoffe dass wir nächstes wochenende das ding auf github hochladen können als
als beta version die paketracker ab die hat mittlerweile alle tracking sachen
bis auf amazon drin die paket tracking ab und sie kann email scan nach paketnummern
werderboy96 nice subscriber
ok jetzt mache ich aber das richtige auf noch mehr product gte twitch prime geht
aber ab hier eigentlich schön was macht ein postkasten
du meinst den du meinst den esp 32 postkasten der ist immer noch nicht
ver eit
aber das spackt mega rum wo ist das problem
läuft das jetzt ok leute ich habe keine ahnung was ich getrieben habe
ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht ok ich habe sie irgendwie ist auch egal ich
habe sie irgendwie ich habe sie irgendwie zerstört weiß nicht was ich
gemacht habe f f für das ppega board wie geht das wie kann ich das kaputt
gemacht haben was hat er hier verschmerzen was ist das problem
er wird es nicht rum
krepp da er f board und warum runter das nicht was ist das denn
ja das ist doch drinne port 5000 richtig das ist genau das richtige warum
runter das nicht was ist das problem
ich habe keine ahnung ich glaube ich habe ein paket update gemacht jetzt
backt es auch egal zumindest frage ich mich gerade ob sich das lohnt das ding
zu kaufen weil das ist übertrieben teuer und kann ich viel mehr als die
andere weil ich mal überlegt euch das mal die würde mir theoretisch nicht ganz
moment moment guckt das falsch ich brauche die kabel fritz box hier genau ich
weiß nicht ob ich mir das ding holen soll ob sich der aufpreis lohnt weil
guck mal die kostet 269 die kostet 194 was für mucke ist das das ist
irgendein irgendein music no vocals schildstab mix 2016 study focus work
also leute für big brains ich weiß nicht ob sich das lohnt ehrlich gesagt
weil ich also prinzipiell würde ich sagen ja wer weiß vielleicht habe ich
gigabit irgendwann mal mit unity media hast du das mit mail scan im stream
gemacht ne habe ich nicht habe ich nicht im stream gemacht aber ich kann es ich
kann es nachher zeigen mich ärger dass das mein chat logger kaputt ist das geht
mir voll auf den chat logger kaputt ich mache jetzt mal ich mache jetzt beim
hintergrunden paket update und da gucken wir uns ein bisschen kommt so was ist
docks ist in docks ist drei das sind kabel modem standards oder kabel kabel
standards
ist im prinzip ein bisschen was wie diese geschichte diese mit dsl hatten wo
sie damit vectoring angefangen haben und damit super vectoring und so gedürnt
also ist ein bisschen in die richtung ja nur dass ist was was standardisiertes
ist frage wieso braucht man so viel download upload ja zum downloaden und
uploaden
wenn du was runterlädt mehrere gigabyte dann fürs 400 mbit upload nice und wenn
du videos hochlädt oder aber stream ist natürlich 40 mbit upload auch gut zumal
man sich überlegen muss in kombinationen mit wenn man wenn man spielt und die
leitung quasi dicht macht mit irgendwas spielt sich natürlich auch nicht so
ordentlich gut deswegen ist eigentlich eigentlich ganz nice
ja das ist baro das war klar dass der hier wieder
das ist baro klein wieder
so also fangen wir mal an also wie gesagt mich würde es mal interessieren ich
weiß nicht ob jemand von euch schon die die sind die sich den euer ich bin ja
ich gar kein fan von von fritz boxen an sich wir haben früher immer gesagt das
ist die rote pest AVM aber das vielleicht ein bisschen drastisch das
ganze
ich weiß ja nicht ob sich das lohnt wobei ich glaube ich ich werde mir doch
wirklich die hier bestellen gewöhnlich versandfertigt in eins bis zwei
monaten hast du mit denen los ohne drei dankeschön subscriber in
ist in ihr ernst sind die leute so geil auf der neue fritz box teurer ist nicht
immer besser in der regel bei fritz boxen tatsächlich schon weil die neu weil
die teureren einfach dass alles können was die alten können plus noch ein
bisschen mehr aber generell ist das fritz box zeug relativ teuer aber ich
finde es angemessen muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen ich finde warum warum warum
sind die leute so geil auf der fritz box
aber ich muss sagen ich finde die ganze fritz box geschichte angemessen weil es
gibt nichts vergleichbares was so viele so viele funktionen in einem gerät
hat ich mein nix davon ist wirklich herausragend
die firewall in fritz boxen ist dies nicht existent die sagt die routing
funktionen in der fritz boxen fast nicht existent die sacken wie line
unterstützung hat fritz box nicht alles mögliche also fritz box ist kein kein
router kein modem kein fax kein anruf beantworter kein deckding so so richtig
fritz box ist nix richtig aber von allem ein bisschen was seit wann streamst du
seit zwei jahren oder so
also ist gut da die mag ich nicht also ist gut da mag ich nicht weil also
erstens sehen die aus wie wie stellzbomber
zweitens haben die jedes mal guckt ihr mal das ding an das sieht eher aus wie
so wie so wie so eine drohne wenn die um wenn die umdrehst kannst du leute die
angst vor spinnen haben übelst erschrecken stelle euch mal vor ihr habt
angst vor spinnen ihr stellt das ding andersrum hin ja und dann macht ihr eine
lampe daneben und ihr wacht nachts auf und guckt zur richtung tür und das ding
wird von der lampe ange angeleuchtet da kackt ihr euch einball
das sieht cool aus findest du dass das sieht beknackt aus aber muss ich bin
vorbelastet was netzwerkgeräte angeht für mich sehen netzwerkgeräte ungefähr so
aus für mich sehen netzwerkgeräte ungefähr so aus die sehen halt so nach
nichts aus so sieht für mich netzwerk so sieht für mich in switch aus einfach
einfach nach nach switch ohne irgendwas moin jodi xd 100 twitch prime
als dankeschön
ich wusste dass euch mocha gefällt wobei mein persönlicher mein
persönlicher favorit ist immer noch wubb lull wubb lull ist das beste
no game no life warum kann ich das überhaupt lesen
switch prime als dankeschön
wisse für jeden sub für jeden sub ich hab schon öfters gesagt heute für jeden
sub steigt der kollektive chat chat chat chat wir sind nicht in afrika zu lull
steigt der chat eq um ein pixel
ok also lange genug ausgelassen über irgendwelche fritzbox sachen
muss ich mich bevor bevor wir uns youtube comments angucken eine sache was
was ich was ich ziemlich frustrierend finde wenn man wieder anfängt mit
youtube das habe ich das letzte mal schon gemerkt die sache ist die ihr
seht es ja hier ich habe gerade 277 483
und wenn man sich mal social plate anguckt
ich zeige jetzt mal was social plate dann wird man feststellen jedes mal wenn
ich mit youtube anfange passiert erst mal das hier das ist der erste tag wo ich
was neues hochlade und dann das ist irgendwie so ein interne youtube
sortier algorithmus dass das hier das ist der erste tag wo ich was hochgeladen
hat youtube hat irgendwie so einen intern sortier algorithmus ich weiß
anders anders anders check ich das nicht das habe ich nämlich die letzten male
schon gemerkt wenn ich wenn ich wochen oder monate inaktiv war das erste was
youtube macht ist die räumen irgendwie inaktive subs auf wenn man videos
hochlädt ganz merkwürdig klar es kommt natürlich auch noch dazu dass
vielleicht der ein oder andere leute das in ihrer sub box haben und sagen hier
der dept das will ich mir nicht mal angucken oder so das kann natürlich auch
sein aber es ist auffällig es ist echt auffällig das ist immer nur dass die
burst quasi immer nur den tag verteilt über den tag nach dem upload kommen und
das geht ungefähr man sieht ja hier immer es geht leider nicht so ganz
zurück ja man sieht sehr immer immer wenn ich wieder aktiv geworden bin hier
habe ich wieder viel hochgeladen hier habe ich wieder viel hochgeladen
immer immer an der stelle wo ich viel hochgeladen habe jetzt geht es halt
aufwärts sieht man ja also immer wenn ich lang viel hochgeladen habe wohl
gemerkt sieht man das immer gleich sagt das war meine aktivitätsphase vor einem
jahr zu weihnachten ungefähr und dann wieder und dann wieder hier davor also
man sieht man sieht das ja das ist das ist wirklich auffällig und es ist jedes
mal so dass das dass das übelst übelst runter geht und es dauert so sagen wir
14 tage 14 tage dauert ungefähr bis bis youtube das wieder gecheckt hat dass
man regelmäßig hochlädt und alles subs aufgeräumt hat und das problem dabei
ist dass das vor allem am anfang übertrieben demotivierend ist wenn du
anfängst und macht letztlich wieder videos hoch und das erste was du siehst
ist 123 ist instant abos oder hier 55 abos nach dem video gestern und das
video ist ja nicht schlecht angekommen ich meine das video hat so gute so so
gute like dislike verhältnisse hat behaupte ich jetzt mal wahrscheinlich
kein mensch oder kaum einer auf youtube kennt in einem anderen channel der 2,4
likes und 21 dislikes hat jetzt ernsthaft das verhältnis hätte noch irgendjemand
der sowas der so viel hat also so gute like dislike verhältnisse gibt es
eigentlich fast nie also kann man nicht sagen dass das video irgendwie schlecht
angekommen ist oder sowas aber es ist halt youtube sortierungsgeschichte das ist
am anfang wirklich extrem demotivierend kann ich euch sagen
deswegen mache ich das diesmal anders ich habe so den hang dazu immer zu
gucken wie das wie das damit subs geht nachdem ich wieder was hochgeladen
habe ich sehe das ja auch bei mir in den statistiken ich habe sobald ich
anfangen hochzuladen kriege ich viel mehr neue subs oder generell viel mehr subs
als vorher aber habe aber auch extrem viel dis abos genau wie wir
deabonnieren ja nicht mehr wir dis abonnieren nur deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht diesmal scheiß drauf ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal ich werde
einfach nichts hochladen wo ich selbst irgendwie kein hundertprozentig gutes
gefühl habe also sprich weil ich habe mir so überlegt wenn ich ein
hundertprozentig gutes gefühl habe hinter dem video wenn ich sage du
hättest an dem video eigentlich jetzt nix wirklich besser machen können so direkt
natürlich besser machen kann man immer was aber ihr wisst ihr wie ich meine ich
weiß ich lade das hoch schalte das frei wenn ich freischalte denke ich ja max
das ist ein richtig gutes video das würdest du dir auch selbst angucken dann ist mir
es egal weil sonst macht sonst mache ich da nicht weiter das klappt sonst nicht
wenn ich mir das angucke wenn ich mir jetzt erstmal 14 tage deabos angucken
muss bis ich youtube wieder erholt hat da habe ich wieder kein bock mehr
deswegen mache ich das jetzt so ich mache einfach videos und ich lade das
hoch wo ich hundertprozent davon überzeugt bin und fertig so ist das so
ist das gedacht mal gucken mal gucken wie gut das wie gut das ganze funktioniert es
wird zu wenig nice gesagt in meinen videos ich weiß viel sehr sehr nice
sage ich öfters oder oder mega nice habe ich übrigens den arm x hunter
gesagt und subscribed tier 1 huge bist du noch am start glaube ich auch ganz
vergessen also chat chat iq steigt wie in sub habe ich ja gesagt
ein bisschen wir haben schon wir also muss sagen und chat ist schon ganz schön
ganz schön intelligent heute gestartet normalerweise startet chat
intelligenz ungefähr so aber ich habe gedacht heute sind wir mal großzügig und
chat intelligenz startet hier irgendwo und falls ich irgendwas über sehe leute
müsst ihr etwas vorbeischreiben weil leider ist mein mein chat mein chat
logging ist kaputt ja ich weiß nicht warum es nicht startet keine ahnung
deswegen sehe ich das nicht ich sehe es zwar auf meinem vorschau bildschirm links
aber ich habe keine history das heißt so viel chat wie hier gerade gechattet wird
sehe ich das nicht deswegen falls ich irgendwas übersetzt über sehe komplett
wirst du mich noch mal andere müssen mich noch mal anschreiben für den normalen
der hexer sagt für den normalen haushalt haushalt sind die kisten von
vm absolut top und laufende regel ohne große zinger ich weiß ich finde ganz
ehrlich ich fand früher vm habe ich vm immer geflammt ich sage wir haben
damals so so zeiten wo ich noch ein bisschen netzwerkzeug gemacht habe oder
mehr netzwerkzeug haben immer auch spaß gesagt die rote pest aus berlin
ich habe vm kommt aus berlin aber mittlerweile muss ich sagen das ist das
sind richtig gute kombi geräte die sind in nichts gut ja wie gesagt die
routin funktionen sind sind reudig
get schwift die 1297 habe ich dich schon erwähnt auf jeden fall ohne 3 auch
nice ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich euch alle vorgelesen habe aber für die
ganzen subs warum eigentlich fritz poch die dinger sind zu teuer für das was
sie bieten die finde ich gar nicht ich finde dass das eigentlich recht
angemessen ist für das was man kriegt wenn du kriegst von allem etwas versuch
mal gute einzelne geräte zu finden versuch mal einen guten guten deck
to woib geschichte zu finden der sich so easy konfigurieren lassen und jetzt
jetzt kein jetzt nicht sagen wie nass asterix aufsetzen oder sowas das ist
ja auch keine keine alternative oder wenn will ich nass brauche ist mit der
fritz box auch gut dabei wenn die gäste wählen für easy mode gäste wählen
brauche es auch gut dabei für mich für mich ist die deckt funktion wichtig für
mich ist die kabel kabel streaming funktion wichtig kabel tv streaming
funktion wichtig dass ist das gut mit mit den fritz points zusammen kann dass man
schön schön seine seine lex cloud kontakte sinken kann und so was in der
richtung also ich finde für das was die fritz box bietet ist die gar nicht so
übel du sagst dass du eventuell mehr technik videos und mythen machen willst
warte mal was denn so im stil von the turtle tubes die leider nichts mehr
machen ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig
dran erinnern weiß ich muss mal gucken max du hattest vor ein paar jahren mal
so eine serie gestartet wurde am ende eines jahres gute pc bilds forschers
hättest du so was interesse wenn du technik krams machen willst ja ich würde
ganz gerne was also ansonsten kann ich immer ihn hier immer ihn hier empfehlen
fähige leute zumal man es auch bei ihm direkt bestellen kann und da weiß ich
dass die sich tatsächlich wirklich groß große mühe geben ja
ich kann sich immer empfehlen und ich habe mir überlegt ob wir nicht zu
weihnachten zusammen wieder ein video technik video krams machen können wie
letztes vorletztes jahr wann haben wir ein video ich glaube letztes jahr haben
ein video zusammengemacht das wäre nice
wohl so also fangen wir mal die youtube comments ansatzschwätzeln wir so lang
also es gab wirklich richtig nice comments diesmal muss man sagen die
call of duty fanboys waren wieder am start ich wollte schon ein video machen
so nach dem motto max flame zuschauer oder sowas in der richtung aber ich habe
mir gedacht wir müssen uns ja nicht übertreiben wir machen einfach einen
stream wo ich euch flamen kann weiß next next level was hältst du von
ubiquity gut die ich habe zwei ich habe zwei sachen von den stürmisch drei drei
sachen ich habe zwei access points zwei mittlerweile habe ich zwei access points
von denen und dann zehn gigabit switch und den da
und den da zwölf mal sfp plus 10 g und vier mal kopfer 10 g wo ist denn der
dark mode den das ist eine gute frage habe ich nicht an könnte den könnte ich
aber mal anmachen
dark mode aktiv der sieht aber kacke aus der dark mode hatte youtube nicht selbst
mittlerweile in dark mode hat er hatte youtube nicht selbst in dark mode
mittlerweile er hat noch selbst in dark mode glaube ich wo kann man den
einschalten ja dark theme da wunderbar huge huge dark theme ja das ist doch
schon viel angenehmer viel angemeldet angenehm
moin austria moin moin zurück leider kein winke winke winke emote ja es
gab hier wirklich viele viele nice comments und ich gehe das jetzt mal
schnell durch ja also wir gucken uns nicht jedes einzelne comment an ich habe
so ungefähr im kopf was was was für gute comments gegeben hat also was ich
sehr nice fand vor allem im ersten video das ist ja das erste was ich
wieder hochgeladen habe dass so viele leute noch am start waren vor allem so
viele leute 2010 auch schon dabei waren aber wenn das hier liest ich mein im
ersten video ist was das eigentlich für ein thumbnail hier bei der games da
wieder wahrscheinlich ist diese szene in dem video drei sekunden lang und voll
that you bait um das video anzuklicken also das fand ich sehr nice dass so viele leute von 2010 dabei sind mit dual mit dem
friseur das wird wahrscheinlich nix das ich habe immer noch kontakt mit dem
fabian also ich meine ich kann den fabian vor youtube schauen und ich kenne
natürlich immer noch aber der fabian hat keinen Bock mehr auf youtube
ich gehe dem ab und zu schon mal auf den keks dass wir was machen aber der will
nicht hallo donkt aber der will nicht ich glaube das wird nix also ein video
zusammen mit dem fabian wird wahrscheinlich kompliziert
bein knalli bär auf den keks versteht ja wubb lull wubb lull
moin wie geht es deinen hoden was interessiert sich das was geht das geht
das in richtung es ist keine schande mehr heutzutage kann es ruhig fragen muss
ich nicht aber ich kann nicht bereuen ist alles in bester verfassung alles
wunderbar also dual mit dem friseur wird es wahrscheinlich geben weil der friseur
kein bock hat um es mal kurz zu sagen warum hat der evoli kein keks vornamen
stimmt warum hat der evoli kein keks vornamen ich glaube da muss ich dem evoli
mal eine sub sub spendieren ach ich kann ja wieder nicht oder es funktioniert ja
auf meiner pforsch auf das sebaro ist ja gut jetzt übertreibt man nicht da
brauche ich extra brauche extra immer und für das sebaro wieder hier mit wie
viel wie viel subs haben wir hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 subs und insgesamt hat
er sebaro schon 28 abos gesponsort sebaro hast du nicht erst deine ausbildung
fertig gemacht gib mal dein geld gibt man gibt dein geld sinnvoll aus gibt es
nicht mir hab schon genug kam damit über die runden du musst hier nicht muss
ich ja nicht verausgaben aber dankeschön für die ganzen abos den haben wir jetzt
am start alle gesponsert vom sebaro den flame haze haben wir jetzt auch öfters
am start beiden der boss ftw der kommt mir auch bekannt vor snow gde dann haben
wir den morpheus 420 presque one hand project l 3 3 3 3 3 3 3 3 3 3 3 3 3 on
german trey und choose my name der ist auch öfters am start helldog österreich auch
am start pock dankeschön und der noah 0302 heute jetzt ist ja mal gut jetzt
übertreibt zwar nicht komme ich dazu nix ja wobei was heißt tos eigentlich
muss ich jetzt ich muss ich jetzt gerade jetzt gerade mit den riesen sellout
starten so nach dem motto habe ich schon erwähnt dass wenn ihr euer amazon
prime account mit twitch verbindet das ganze dann zu twitch prime kombiniert
dass ihr einmal im monat kostenlos einen streamer eurer wahl unterstützen
könnt mit einem tier 1 sub euch kostet das ganze nix und dem streamer bringt
das alle vorteile die ein normaler sab auch bringt plus ihr kriegt natürlich
nice emotes sowas wie wub lull wub s wub old und wub kap was hier besiedelt
immer schon haben haben wollte das da merkt ist auch am start mit beim
dankeschön nice kannst du mal ein dual da ein dual mit dem doctor kaboom machen
max ich habe in letzter zeit wenig mit dem kaboom zu tun gehabt
allerdings ist ein dual mit dem kaboom wahrscheinlicher als mit dem friseur
weil der friseur hat absolut kein bau mehr auf youtube geht das auf dem keks
omega warum habe ich eigentlich mein keks avatar nicht drinnen wie steht es mit einem
staubsäure läuft da schon doom drauf garantiert also du dürfte das gleich das
kleinste problem sein baba saft 439 twitch prime
angeschön jetzt geht es aber ab ich komme gar ich komme zu nix ich meine ich will
mich mal nicht beschweren jetzt irgendwie das war falsche
der thomas m07 angeschön für den sab normalerweise zelebriere ich ja einen
sab etwas mehr aber gerade geht es echt schlag auf schlag danke für die ganzen
subs öffne fifa packs mit commander krieger also ich würde mit commander
krieger was aufnehmen aber fifa packs vor allem allgemein mal was frage in die
runde leute warum gibt es so viele leute die fifa packs kaufen außer
wenn es irgendwelche krassen influencer dudes auf youtube sind die dann bei
eskalieren
ich meine er kennt er die fifa pack openings oder was geht dr. swag ist
wieder am start und heute mache ich 50 fifa packs auf alle ich freue mich so ich
bin so gehyped diese fifa dinger jetzt endlich aufzumachen und endlich gibt es
wieder was und dann gibt es dann gibt es die andere dann gibt es die anderen die
die das nicht halten die die immer so ganz cool sind sowas in so was in
richtung was ist in richtung aber abholt so nach dem olo liga liga liga hab ich
schon mein neuer sonn kommt liga kritischer hase liga liga die gibt es
auch noch aber aber die die dr. swag eskaliert tippen gibt gibt es doch der
swag heißt das wäre irgendwie ein guter guter vielfalt pack opening name
nerven kitzel die sucht ok
das ist das einzige was ich mir da gemerkt habe
weiß gar nicht ob er das überhaupt noch sagt
grazio ist zwei monate aktuell nice dankeschön
ich meine es kann jeder machen was er will nur weil ich gerne fifa packs
kauf weiß nicht dass ich leute irgendwie verurteilen würde die sich
fifa packs kaufen ich kann es bloß nicht ganz nachvollziehen
apuret ist noch ein denke ich weiß es nicht habe mir das bloß gemerkt dass
er manchmal gesagt hat kritischer hase und ganz ganz wichtig heutzutage als
als influencer wie man das jetzt ja nennt das ist ja ist ja erst seit so
zwei drei jahren dass das dass es da so richtig ist mal drei jahre seit das
so richtig ist richtig dieses nices wort für gibt ja du musst auf jeden fall
irgendeinen irgendeinen schlechten rap song aufnehmen zum beispiel zum
beispiel kannst du dann es ist es ist im prinzip egal was du sagst du kannst
das eh autotune oder sowas also ein paar schlechte so ein paar schlechte so ein
paar schlechte dreime und so ein paar schlechte sachen müssen da rein so
irgendwie so wie nach dem motto was habe ich heute auf auf twitter gelesen
dein vater ist plau wie das discord logo was wäre das könnte man so
informatiker rap machen
hören wir den song von bibi an hat ihn schon wieder was neues gesungen die
schon wieder was neues ich hoffe nicht ich glaube den ist hier
ich glaube sogar katja krasawitzel hat jetzt einen hat jetzt auch irgendwas
gesungen muss echt jeder singen muss wirklich uns wirklich echt jeder singen
mittlerweile vor allem da verstehe ich auch nicht was die an der also ich kann
mir ja verstehen ich kann ja verstehen dass es leute gibt die streamer oder
youtuber gucken einfach nur weil sie die geil finden also mit geil finden
meine ich jetzt nicht weil sie den content geil finden sowas weil sie die
personen geil finden ja weil ihnen da voll einer drauf abgeht kann ich
verstehen was ich nicht verstehen kann ist warum man katja krasawitzel geil
findet der lost hat es letztens treffend gesagt
die sieht aus wie er wie hat er gesagt
ich krieg sie zusammen das war die beste beschreibung nicht der je gehört
habe es sieht aus wie ein invertiertes bild oder irgendwie sowas die
beschreibung trifft genau das ist wie wenn du einfach ein photoshop filter
nimmst oder machst du farb invertieren und so ungefähr kommt mir das teilweise
vor wie sie in den videos rumspringen ja aber selbst wenn man notgeile kiddies
ist es gibt so viel bessere auf youtube oder auf twitch die man sich angucken
kann es gibt sogar welche dass die kombinationen
ist selten ja gebe ich zu aber es gibt ja sogar welche die spielen ganz gut und
die sehen auch gut aus
alternativ sucht man sich halt einfach jemand der nur gut aussieht da ist ich
kann das nicht verstehen weil man auch mittlerweile auswahl
guckt geht auf twitch geht auf geht auf twitch in in in just chatting geht da
hin du wirst du wirst so viele so viele
medals finden hier und wenn wirklich irgendjemand das nötig hat sich das
anzugucken wegen irgendwelche medals dann soll er sich doch hier lieber hier
irgendjemand raussuchen der ihm gefällt und da ein bisschen fanboy anstatt sich
katja krasawitzel anzugucken wozu
ich melde dich vor eurer mission an was ist denn nun mit kommentaren ja stimmt
da hast du recht
weil keine war classic weil wenn ich jetzt anfangen mit war classic mache ich
keine youtube videos keine streams
stonehenge abonniert auf stufe 1 stonehenge auf auf stonehenge habe ich
mal in da gespielt das war hieß damals so da ist halt kein menschen ahnung von
was ich rede übrigens habe gesagt mit jedem sub steigt der chat IQ IQ sagt man
ja heute nicht mehr muss alles steil ist doch nicht agil man ist agile
mittlerweile sind wir eigentlich schon bei durch die ganzen subs sind wir
eigentlich schon maximierter iku für heute sagen wir müssen erst mal ein IQ
IQ reset durchführen dass es überhaupt noch draufpasst
dankeschön für den sub kriss stonehenge das ist ja ok habe ich nix dagegen bloß
die frage wenn man da beim real life zuguckt wie gesagt habe ich habe es ja
gesagt eine million abos face reveal ich mache das problem ist nur ich
werde nie im leben eine million abos kriegen aber ich habe mir was überlegt
ich habe ich habe mir was überlegt das kann jetzt auch kurz los wenn ich habe
was überlegt und zwar man könnte man könnte weil man seinem chat immer so
lustig darüber machen ich habe gedacht ich müsste ich muss mir was
realistisches was realistisches ziel setzen ja habe ich gesagt ok 300.000
subs ich meine da fehlen noch 23.000 23.000 300.000 subs ja also das heißt
dass ich das packe muss ich erst mal stabil uploaden content den die leute
sehen wollen plus vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen mit mit anderen was machen
dann ist das denke ich ein realistisches ziel und dann mache ich hier mache ich
ein so was mache ich dann das ist mir übelst peinlich das kann ich jetzt schon
sagen aber das ist wenigstens was das ist mir übelst peinlich aber das bei 300.000
ist das so was wo ich mich dazu durchregen könnte so was zu machen
aber richtig das ist das ist massiver paint schimpf
das ist krönschow zähler
stelle ich mir nicht so an sonst mache ich euch gleich 30 minuten ASMR
feuchte mundgeräusche an oder sowas hier auf youtube
wollte das wirklich haben ja
nein wenn jetzt noch mache ich nicht an
schon gleich die ersten neuer ja krank ist toll ich dachte ich kann euch damit
jetzt abschrecken aber nee klappt mal wieder nicht twitter chat also cute cute
chat ist abgehärtet gegen alles mögliche
youtube comments wir wollten youtube comments gucken also dual kommentare mit
dem friseur schon erwähnt bleibt auch bitte dran mit das haben auch
saumäßig viele leute geschrieben ich werde versuchen ja ich wie gesagt ich
habe die letzten jahre gesehen ich war das hauptproblem ist kann ich jetzt mal
sagen sind ja ein paar von youtube da übrigens leute die von youtube die von
youtube angerückt sind wollte mal einen staubsauger sehen ich kann noch mal
staubsauger web oberfläche vor einem staubsauger zeigen
staubsauger web oberfläche ich habe web interface auf meinem staubsauger
ja was wollte ich jetzt sagen fuck genau das hauptproblem was ich habe mit
aktiv bleiben auf youtube das ist das was mir die ersten paar jahre über
geholfen hat ist ich brauche ein spiel was ich kreiten kann ich brauche ein
spiel was ich durchgängig spielen kann ich hatte zuerst massig call of duty
danach hatte ich massig battlefield combat company 2 bis bis battlefield 4
ein ticken hardline noch und das fehlt mir aktuell ich habe kein grinding game
auf youtube nicht so geil allerdings spiele ich auch gerade kann
overwatch mehr ich habe überlegt ich könnte mal wieder weil immer noch weil
immer noch leute nach overwatch fahren ich könnte mal meine placement matches
aufnehmen und da so ein best of zusammen schnippeln
danach dem motto ex pro lucio sagt auf lucio oder irgendwie sowas apex apex ist
für mich das beste bettel royale game von fortnite pupke und apex apex
altes battlefield ich habe mir ich habe eine bett company 2 gameplay aufgenommen
das wollte ich demnächst hochladen hast du dann high end klo noch klar
es ist so voller cheater apex wirklich ich hoffe ich habe jetzt keine subs
übersehen so viel wie gerade gekommen sind wir haben alle also ich versuche
es wie gesagt ich kann ich kann nichts versprechen was was videos angeht ihr
habt das die letzten jahre mitgekriegt aber ich probiere es das es es hängt
auch ein bisschen daran also themen habe ich genug ich habe mir
mittlerweile ich habe mir die ersten paar tage so viel aufgeschrieben und und
richtig gute ideen zum beispiel heute im discord einer eine richtig gute idee
gehabt so nach dem motto ideen in direkt eigentlich nur idee wir könnten unser
eigenes google stadia bauen jetzt nicht wir mieten uns kein rechenzentrum und
bauen google stadia als server mäßig nach aber es gibt mittlerweile richtig
gute software die nix kostet wo man low latency spiele streamen kann von einem
pc an ein endgerät
und das ist mit sicherheit ähnlich gut wenn man in der nähe wohnt wie google
stadia wenn man wenn man einen ordentlichen gaming pc hat natürlich
na ich bin persönlich immer noch der ansicht dass google stadia übel flotten
wird und die letzten jahre muss dazu geben habe ich meistens ganz gut
gelegen mit sachen die flotten und auch mit sachen die sich das ist ja max das
orakel ich weiß aber und auch sachen die sich durchsetzen ich habe ich von
anfang an gesagt als pupke der halb schlechthin war und fortnight
rausgekommen ist und alle gesagt aber nur fortnight beste pupke pupke viel
besser und so fortnight habe ich damals habe ich schon vor ein oder vor zwei
jahren oder so leute pupke wird abscheißen höchstens in asien sogar
das habe ich damals gesagt höchstens in asien das ist das ist hier big brain
next level aber fortnight wird sich durchsetzen und was ist in asien ist
pupke noch beliebt und fortnight ist kacke in asien
und hier ist fortnight extrem huge und pupke interessiert sich nicht mehr so
richtig einer für warum denkst du das mit stadia
ich sehe ich sehe nicht so richtig warum man sich das kaufen sollte die größte
größte okay das ist ja zählt ja quasi als als kommend beantworten die größten
teile der gamer wenn man sie mal so nennen darf sind mobile spielende
casuals die spielen was gibt es denn da so hier clash clash of clans und und
happy bird und geschiss ja die leute kaufen sich kein stadia allein schon
wenigen controller in der hand haben da denkst du das ist für die das ist das
ist das check nicht die wissen gar nicht wie man das halten soll
ich dachte ich der witz ist so schlecht da steigt keiner drauf ein ja aber
anscheinend doch so wollte ich jetzt sagen die werden sich wahrscheinlich
auch kein stadia holen was bleibt dann übrig die leute die hardcore playstation
fans sind warum sollten diese stadia holen die wollen die wollen playstation
exclusives spielen höchstens die xbox leute davon gibt es zumindest in
deutschland nicht so viele allerdings die die wirklich auch große xbox fans sind
auf die exklusiv titel wie halo stehen die spiele mittlerweile entweder
windows oder auf der xbox und die wollen wahrscheinlich auch kein stadia also das
einzige was übrig bleibt für stadia sind eigentlich leute die gerne pc oder
oder sagen wir die gerne spiele spielen wollen hauptsächlich in single player
weil über multiplayer vergiss es und dafür sich ein abo holen wollte also ich
sehe es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig
ja das weiß ich stadia hat auch gesagt sie sind enttäuscht wenn sie nur 2
millionen user haben
das mag sein ich weiß nicht aber google google hat auch eine so ein bisschen
bisschen geschichte in letzter zeit komische dinge herauszubringen ich mein
denk mal an google plus und die zwangsintegration mit youtube und so
was oder 200 millionen 200 und nicht 2 millionen 200 millionen war es stimmt
2 millionen 2 millionen 2 millionen hat schon mario maker verkauft wahrscheinlich
ja deswegen glaube ich dass stadia flotten wird die einzige sache die
stadia glaube ich warum sollten sich pc spieler stadia holen
zum beispiel pc spieler die gerne pc spielen wollen aber sich kein pc holen
wollen oder halt generell leute die vielleicht früher pc gespielt haben
und sagen hey ich würde auch aktuelle ich würde gerne aktuelle single player
spiele auch spielen aber vielleicht halt unterwegs vielleicht auch bei mir
daheim aber ich habe keine ordentlichen pc vielleicht multiplayer über stadia
kann funktionieren allerdings nur unter der voraussetzung dass die restliche
welt auch stadia verwendet was die restliche welt nicht tun wird stadia
multiplayer funktioniert nur wenn du lobbies bilden kannst oder server in in
die google cloud stellen kannst dass quasi die latency zwischen dem spieler
und den server weg fällt also die noch mal extra latency also du hast ja schon
latency durch input und und streaming an denjenigen der stadia verwendet aber
wenn wenigstens die spieler untereinander auf dem gleichen server sind so ein
bisschen wie bei einem mmo dann könnte das funktionieren aber das klappt nur
wenn die ganze welt stadia für multiplayer verwendet oder aber stadia
spiel isoliert miteinander
ich verstehe es auch nicht es wird wenn die mir nicht zeigt das einzige ich sage
euch mal was das einzige ist was mich was mich überzeugen würde dass das das
stadia spielen lokales spielen
übertrumpfen könnte das einzige das einzige wo die mir das erzählen könnten
ist wenn cs go ein team ein major gewinnt über stadia
dann glaube ich denen dass das so revolutionär ist wie sie wie sie wie sie
wie sie tun das wird aber nicht passieren
keiner kein cs pro spielt freiwillig den major über stadia die lachen die lachen
nicht eher die die lagen nicht aus wenn du das denen vorschlägt das ist das
einzige wurde mich mit über über über überzeugen könnten aber ansonsten hat
stadia schon jemand mal aus poet wie ist das mit der lizenz mit der latenz ich
habe letztens einen artikel zu stadia gelesen wo sie irgendwas um zu wo sie
irgendwie mit 200 millisekunden rum gegrüßt sind das halte ich persönlich
für ein bisschen hoch
es ist aber auch nichts neues das muss man ja auch mal sehen diese ganze gaming
und dem an streaming geschichte die gibt es seit 2012 oder so online
vereintes der ersten den ich weiß gar nicht so online überhaupt noch gibt
die kamer im betrieb 2011 2015 eingestellt dazu kommt ja noch dass es
playstation now gibt oder wie das ganze heißt oder sowas in der richtung also
stadia ist jetzt ja nichts neu ist das einzige das den einzigen riesen
vorteil den youtube hat den ich den youtube hat in den google hat ist ihre
infrastruktur vor allem die in vor allem die länder wo sie google fiber und so
gedönst gibt das ist der ein das ist der einzige vorteil den google im
vergleich zu anderen anbietern hat dass sie eben massig infrastruktur haben und
das ist übrigens auch das einzige wie das funktionieren wird wenn du game
streams und sei es single player die server müssen irgendwo bei dir in der
nähe stehen weil schneller als lichtgeschwindigkeit geht halt nicht
wie soll das funktionieren ich mein google hat zwar schlaue leute aber wenn
sie schaffen würden die datenschneller als lichtgeschwindigkeit zu übertragen
ich glaube da werden die leute nicht mehr bei google da würden die würden
die gesamte menschheit revolutionieren und die stadia bauen
und ansonsten wo die zeit drauf geht ist ja nicht unbedingt bei der reinen
übertragung jedes paket was irgendwie geroutet werden muss bei jedem hopp
landet es mal kurz in einem buffer muss look abgemacht werden tabelle das sind
immer immer millisekunden halbe millisekunden je nachdem was ist unterwegs
und wenn oder 80 hops dazwischen hast oder so wird das nix das kann nicht
ordentlich funktionieren das komprimieren das dauert es ist es ist
nicht ohne max vor 30 min und erst mal kommen zu lesen max jetzt google stadia
ja ist doch fast ein comment stadia kamen sogar in den comments manchmal
manchmal vorm muss muss man muss jetzt muss ich jetzt einfach mal loswerken
habe ich irgendwas überlesen oder der presskart gefragt ich mache zur zeit
eine ausbildung als fachinformatiker und habe irgendwie keine ahnung wie ich ein
praktikumsplatz für meinen abschluss wie kannst du eine ausbildung als
fachinformatiker machen und du brauchst einen praktikumsplatz
in der ausbildung als fachinformatiker hast hast du doch hast du den aber
das platz
das check ich nicht das ist zu next level für mich
nach umschulung aber du hast was anderes gelernt und macht es jetzt
quasi zu jetzt nicht noch mal was dass du dass du fache in fachinformatiker
kriegst gute frage
keine lust auf so einen ausnutzerbetrieb ganz ehrlich wenn du
dann praktikum machen willst das geht wie lang geht das acht wochen
scheiß doch drauf ob das ein ausnutzerbetrieb ist du musst dich ja nicht
ausnutzen lassen die könne hier nicht rausschmeißen
nach drei monate
also wenn du natürlich die möglichkeit hast was ordentliches zu finden natürlich
dann dann würde ich auf jeden fall was interessantes nehmen keine frage aber
wenn es einfach nur darum ging dass du den krams jetzt endlich hinter dir hast
du musst ja jeder ein projekt machen also sprich drei monate lager aufräumen
geht überhaupt nicht drei monate lager aufräumen ist nicht
bestandteil der ausbildung und außerdem bist du da um dein abschlussprojekt zu
machen also ich glaube außerdem kommt dazu so viele es ist jetzt auch nicht so
dass jeder dass jeder betrieb irgendwie die übelsten ausnutzer werden ja es
gibt da schon genug leute die sich azubis einstellen um quasi billige
arbeitskräfte zu haben mit mitteln die meisten sind das war weitem nicht die
meisten sind vielleicht unfähig aber die meisten haben nicht gezielt vor die
leute auszubeuten in der richtung drei monate im bergwerk was wir
fachinformatiker ausbildung im bergwerk was willst du den bergwerk fach
informatikern raspberry pi für fachstuhl steuerung
und geht das den kaputten die leute kommen die wieder raus also aber ich muss
dir sagen also vorschläge habe ich nicht so wirklich was ganz ok ist was du
machen könntest ist bei einem shop portal was ich konnte heise jobs oder
irgendwas in einem shop portal einfach mal zu gucken wer fachinformatiker oder
wer generell also einmal fachinformatiker ausbildungsstellen anbietet
die sind natürlich nicht verkehrt mal zu fragen kannst du nicht da dein
praktikum machen es gibt auch welche die haben explizit wenn du dann auf die
homepage gehst dieser leute in job portals haben sie keine praktikumsstellen
drinstehen meistens aber du kannst auf das du siehst ja auf dem job portal
meistens wer es ist sei das ist so ein anonymisierungs ding und da kannst du
bei denen auf der homepage gucken ob die nämlich leute suchen für praktikum
manche schreiben viele mittlerweile auch auf die auf die webseite und ansonsten
ganz ehrlich sucht ihr irgendwas was bei dir in der nähe ist dass du das jetzt
die drei monate easy auf einer auf der halben arschpacke machst und du machst
ja jeder ein projekt da die könne ich ja gar nicht großartig ausbeuten
ok weiter jetzt das haben auch so viele leute geschrieben wie sehr sie sich
freuen dass videos wieder am start sind sie haben das früher geguckt wo sie
zwölf waren oder so okay und da habe ich mir gedacht alles übertreibt das einer
hat geschrieben irgendwie aber zwölf würde angefangen meine videos zu gucken
das problem ist das ist ohne probleme möglich ich habe 2010 angefangen wenn
er 2000 wenn er 2010 zwölf hat das in neun jahre dann ist er jetzt 21 quick
maps
überlegt euch das mal das oder jemanden mit zwölf angefangen hat meine videos
zu gucken ist jetzt 21 kann man sich das vorstellen
kräftig oder ich meine ich ja auch ich habe angefangen mit paar 20 jetzt bin ich
ja wo alt bin ich jetzt bin ich 35 eine runde mal wo alt für mich in chat wer
kann richtig wo alt feels alt schenke
du hast dich immer noch jung an ich weiß ich habe mich schon immer angehört
wie 14 oder so
neu emotes ja okay ich mache ja meine thumbnails immer noch mit affinity
designer meine thumbnails sind jetzt nicht sonderlich gut aber es ist auf
jeden fall besser als ich auf irgendwelche design soll zu verlassen die
alle paar monate nicht mehr wollen oder irgendwie dann sich was anders
überlegt haben oder so oder jetzt minecraft reaction sonst was youtuber
sind oder ich weiß gar nicht was macht er denn
jetzt eigentlich
machen die gibt es ihn noch
ja die gibt es noch aber immer noch ordentlich views
wirst du mal mittlerweile haben meine ehemaligen thumbnail designer zehnmal
mehr abos und views als ich 50 mal mehr 50 mal mehr abos und views als ich ist
aber nicht so dass ich keinen gönnen wird letztendlich ich finde den konter
immer ein bisschen fragwürdig von manchen leuten aber wenn es wenn es einem
gefällt war das nicht auch der mit geld ist geld oder so was
hast du zwei zwei monate aktuell dankeschön
poch ich sollte dann thumbnail designer werden kannst du gerne machen wenn du
wenn du gut sein kannst ich kann es nicht guckt ihr meine thumbnails an
also wann kommt die minecraft let's play reihe auf dem staubsauger erstmal muss
den kram irgendwie als erstes muss ich dem staubsauger mal einen usb stick
verpassen und hoffen dass er den erkennt mach mal wieder ein laba stellst
mit plans versus zombies habe ich tatsächlich vor es gab es letztens
kostenlos bei origin
ich habe erst letztens das flawless akimbo gameplay von dir und thunder
angeschaut gute zeit ja den gibt es auch noch nicht
nice letztens wieder was geguckt von dem
aber dein kot vier videos mit friseur und dieser dame geliebt keine ahnung wie
sie heißt man sylvaner die sylvaner die sylvaner gibt es auch noch die sylvaner
ist ausgewandert so war als letztes was ich mit gekriegt habe die sylvaner ist
ausgewandert immer hier hey kommens
asitoni das rutscht mir manchmal so raus ja was meint ihr was überlegt euch
mal leute der asitoni würde heutzutage dieses video hochladen
das ist ja mal sowas von gar nicht 2019 feminismus tauglich der asitoni der
wäre der hätte ja die das wäre ja schon instant hate speech das wäre ja geteert
gefedert gebannt gefiertheilt alles wäre heute worden da asitoni
wissen noch alle dass du früher kurz auf der xbox gespielt hast ja aber das ist
fünf jahre oder so her das keyboard kommt zur anwendung er hat recht er hat
nicht unrecht ja er hat nicht unrecht wenn ich aber sehr laut machen nichts
hochladen ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd aber ich habe euch das gerade
gezeigt mit den statistiken erstens bringt aber sehr laut was die leute
denken da einfach nicht dran was sie motiviert tatsächlich wirklich
ungemein weil man sieht dass es aber es gibt
aber auch in paar runden gespielt und mir gefällt es richtig dass die waffen
sich wuchtig anfühlen und nicht als hätte ich eine wasserpistole in der hand
mit der diegel one shots verteilen ist verdammt befrieden das stimmt das hat
mir tatsächlich an der beta auch gefallen das fand ich das fand ich angenehm der
westersburg zum beispiel hat gesagt er mag das nicht erfinden das fühlt sich
ordentlich wie kot an wie geht es dem kabu dem geht es gut zwar schon eine
weile nichts mehr gehört aber dem ging es zuletzt gut ich vermute jetzt immer noch
gut den friseur jetzt auch gut von dem höre ich regelmäßig was der ist da
ist alles aber der friseur kein bock auf youtube lieber kack thumbnails und
cooler inhalt anstelle cooles thumbnail und kack inhalte
wie wäre es mit besonders kack inhalten clickbait titeln und übertrieben
aufgemotzten thumbnails weil das scheint am besten zu funktionieren
das ist next level richtig so muss man es anmachen auf youtube aktuell
ey wie kann man seinen follow age einsehen keine ahnung was du meinst
dass familie ritter wird warum warum wird mir familie ritter vorgeschlagen
ich verstehe youtube nicht
ich juckt familie ritter überhaupt nicht
das erste video hat halt zum größten teil daraus bestanden dass die leute
sich freuen dass wieder videos gibt das hat mich auch gefreut
huge gefreut
ihre genau was mich sehr stark stört ist dieses platzschgeräusch wo man einen
gegner trifft das macht das macht auch das gleiche
hitmarker geräusch wie immer oder der m core ist da jetzt wo ist er haben gar nicht gesehen
dem core da ist er max hast du das game auf der konsole gezeugt habe jetzt gar
nicht aufgepasst dass du ein video hochgeladen hast mich interessiert wie sich
maus auf der konsole anfühlt maus und tastatur auf der ps4 haben sich kacke
angefühlt die ps4 hat eine maus ab tastrate jenseits von gut und böse das
hat im hauptmenü sie hat sich die maus ungefähr so bewegt in game hat sich
besser angefühlt aber nicht nicht wirklich direkt und flüssig ich habe
ich meine ich habe auf der einzigen sense dies in game gab gespielt und 800
dpi mich als ungefähr so eingestellt dass ich einmal übers maus pad in 360
mache und ich habe mich so übertrieben vereimt dass auf dem pc auf jeden fall
nicht vorkommt es funktioniert ganz gut dazu kommt dass ich mir noch so ein so ein
so ein cheat ding gekauft habe sondern so einen wie heißt das diesen diesen ich
habe schon wieder vergessen wie dieses teil heißt steht auch kein name drauf
diese sim geschichte weil ich mir gedacht habe ich komme überhaupt nicht
mit controller klar und mit maus und tastatur an diesem controller adapter
ist halt schon ganz schöner beschiss
aber ich meine warum nicht pc master race konsolen plebs haben es nicht
anders verdient das ist abo max des abo
max nimm mal den nazi frosch aus den thumbnails es ist mittlerweile ja
es ist mittlerweile fast alles nazi du kannst ja nichts mehr verwenden
plus ich wusste gar nicht dass pepe nazi ist mittlerweile aber es ist fast
alles nazi ganz ganz ja nichts war was ich schon alles wenn ich mir das
überlege auf youtube na was mir schon alles vorgeworfen wurde ich war schon
alles ich war von judo bis kanake bis scheiß nazi ich war alles auf youtube
schon alles je nachdem was kann einer hätten wollte war ich schon
max würdest du empfehlen wirtschaftsinformatik zu studieren
kommt auf dich an markierst du immer ein wort oder ein
buchstabe ja also so eine angewohnheit von mir haben wir auch haben wir auch
einen bot kommando also wenn du bvl zeug magst plus ein bisschen technik dann
warum nicht ja also ich mache um alle bvl und wirtschaftssachen immer einen
großen bogen aber das ist persönliche geschichte
mit ps4 remote play ging es einigermaßen echt man kann ps4 remote play machen mit
tastaturen maus echt
bb klau
ja im kohr du hast du musstest ich weiß du musstest den gleichen bist
sicherlich auch schon anderen alle die die auf die längere zeit auf youtube
sind und sag mal eine gewisse reichweite haben wussten die waren schon alles mal
die wurden schon die du wurdest für alles schon geflammt ja du bist auch
gleichermaßen xbox fanboy also kack xbox fanboy kack sony fanboy kack
microsoft fanboy kack amd fanboy kack kack nvidia fernbund ist alles immer
immer so wie es passt gerade ist einfach so
aber die meisten leute und ich denke mal im kohr das bei dir auch so die meisten
leute bei uns sind vollkommen normal sofern man normal sein kann
damals haben alle einen dachschaden ich ja auch irgendwo aber die meisten bei
uns in den comments sind wirklich sehr umgänglich und angenehm und haben
natürlich huge brain klar vor allem wisst ihr wer besonderes großes gehirn
hat das sind alle leute die ihren amazon prime mit twitch prime verbunden haben
weil wenn du deinen amazon prime mit twitch prime verbunden hast kannst du
kostenlos einen streamer unterstützen mit einem prime abo dafür kriegst du ein
paar emotes vom jeweiligen streamer kostet dich nichts und der streamer hat
alle vorteile von easy schon getan echt im kompan hast du mich gesagt danke
nice
ich war mich nicht warum ich jetzt das java emote aufmache einfach weil es
geht weil java
diese random emote naja was heißt die immer immer immer sind nicht random die
sind calculated sind schon sie sind schon auf besonderem besonderem level durch
durchdacht ja trommel mich die twitch prime dankeschön hat schon funktioniert
dankeschön was ist ein all time favorite game
heute ich habe ich mache euch einen vorschlag ich mache einen vorschlag wenn
ihr wenn ihr so fragen habt wie was ist ein all time favorite game oder wenn ihr
dann am besten noch ihr formuliert da irgendwie eine video idee draus die er
gerne hören würdet dann macht einfach mal aus rufe zeichen discord weil wir
haben im discord ein channel für themenvorschläge ich kann mir das eh
nicht alles merken jetzt und haut es da rein und wenn es ein guter vorschlag ist
mache ich die video zu und wenn es ein video ist was von einem vorschlag kommt
welch auch noch rein pastet von ihm der vorschlag ist das ist doch was oder ok
was haben wir sonst noch für schöne comments
bettel viel gameplays leute bettel viel gameplay bad company 2 gameplays schon
aufgenommen haus day und black ops 1 free for all ist
aufgenommen also von mir selbst jetzt nicht irgendwie externe gameplays wieder
solution hat nicht reagiert auf den post ich denke das einfach nicht gesehen
wir haben uns wir haben uns vor vor drei vier drei vier monaten haben wir uns
schon mal überlegt ob wir nicht was zusammen aufnehmen
also wir sind ganz unregelmäßig haben wir uns haben wir uns die letzten jahre
mal wieder ab und zu was geschrieben ich habe mir schon überlegt ob ich nicht
einfach mal weil ich weiß mir folgen ganz viele old school leute und wir
folgen viele leute auf twitter die mal old school waren und jetzt halt jetzt
halt teilweise schon ziemlich groß sind ob ich nicht einfach mal auf twitter
posten sollte wer hat bock was was aufzunehmen mit mir weil du musst
heutzutage auf auf youtube guter content allein ist nur die halbe miete so ein
bisschen cross promotion muss sein und wenn es und und und wenn ich abo retz
neuen song remixen muss ja ganz man kann es auch übertreiben ich mache
einfach back vocals die gar jetzt scherze die gar die gar ja komm mal die
gar flix kohler twitch prime dankeschön pock zwei monate schon oh ich muss
langsam einen drei monats betsch eine drei monats betsch einführen
für meine
du find super gms ich sagte hey max bin super dass du wieder videos macht mit
definitiv auf mehr ich auch ich habe übelst bock ich hatte heute aus weil ich
mache ein video zum thema hat einer ein richtig langes comment geschrieben was
für bauchschmerzen er gerade mit in der schule hat und und und
ausbildungsmäßig mäßig und habe ich mich wieder erkannt drin da wollte ich
eigentlich ausführlich was zu sagen aber ich habe gedacht zwei videos
hintereinander ist ein bisschen ein bisschen verschwendet auch wenn es ein
wichtiges thema ist weil das video sonntag hochgeladen ist halt ein schlechter
tachsonntag abend hat hat erst glaub 15.000 aufrufe oder so ich wollte schon
warten bis das bei ungefähr 20.000 ist vor ich das nächste hochlade
kommen wieder mal bc 2 gameplay habe ich gerade gesagt ich habe schon was
aufgenommen optik jellyfisch oh echte echte optik player
echte optik player dankeschön für den primes ab
der m core sagt jetzt muss ich nur hoffen dass modern warfare auch für
den mc rauskommt jetzt wo ich nur noch ein macbook habe jetzt bereusert
stadia hat was doch gerade von kauf dir einfach im spiel über stadia und und
krieg dich auf dass das das ist leckt german taters 2.0 garantiert nicht den
stress würde ich mir auch nicht geben zumal man heute gar nicht die leute
verfinden würde
du musst einfach nur content für kids machen an selber durch dann ja aber
das beißt sich mit dem was ich am anfang gesagt habe ich habe am anfang
gesagt ich werde ich werde jetzt einen anderen ansatz machen und zwar wenn ich
ein video hochlade ich lade nur noch videos hoch wo ich 100 prozentig selbst
davon überzeugt bin dass es ein video ist was ich gucken würde und da kann ich
kein kinder content machen was mit alt f4 mit thema hatte ich nie groß nichts
großartig zu tun das einzige was mit alt also mit mit mit mit
mit alpha 4 games je zu tun hatte war mal diese also einmal wollten wir mal was
zu bettel viel machen aber das haben wir nie gemacht und dieses dieses dead
dead space drei zeilen programm was ich da mal gebastelt habe
der stampf 1 oder so mach mal was mit m core also ja wir müssen auf jeden fall
was zusammen aufnehmen jetzt das bleibt geht ja gar nicht anders
kommt mit dem chat heute überhaupt nicht nach was ist denn hier los
mach irgendwas mit monta dann hast du deine reichweite wir kennen uns nicht
sonderlich gut ich weiß erstens nicht ob er was mit mir machen will und ich
wüsste auch gar nicht genau was ehrlich gesagt ich weiß ich ob das so gut
zusammenpasst ich war ja schon mal vor uhrzeit habe ich so 20 sekunden klipp
war mal bei ihm auf dem channel in einem längeren video aber das war noch ganz
am anfang und sogar das hat schon ausgebracht damals meine katze an der
tür kratzt die wartet mal kurz macht sie nicht macht sie nicht hab ja ich von
alle meine eine neue katz gesehen
auch wenn der name merkwürdig ist sie heißt schicko und ist ist eine katze
weiß ich warum man warum man seine seine katze schicko nennt anstatt schicka aber
ist so und aber die hört da drauf die das habe ich noch nicht gesehen die
anderen haben sich für ihren namen überhaupt nicht interessiert kaum
sagst du bei schicko schicko geht sofort das ohr hoch so nach dem was ist gibt es
was und ich komme mit dem chat echt nicht hinterher ist der wahnsinn ist nicht
ist nicht möglich gerade wie kriege ich meine beiden rechnen dazu dass ich von
meinem hauptreffende die zweite festplatte vom zweiten rechner über
der exploratoren einfach rechts draufklicken und scheren antrücken das
ist mehlig zu sein ist das aber mit zug story so mal gucken bietet sich auch
mal wieder an also falls ihr was überlesen müsst ihr auf jeden fall
etwa bloß schreien weil ich sehe das nicht man kommt der extra dem
anal penetrierer zurück weiß ich nicht das war übels cringe machen wir wieder
it müten das habe ich geplant
kennst du der thunder lord sagt mir gar nichts ich kenne extrem viele
leute auf youtube nicht mehr also jedes mal wenn ich wenn ich youtube
aufmache kriege ich videos von jemand neu empfohlen der 500.000 plus abos hat
von dem ich im leben noch nichts gehört haben was ist mit anders den gibt es
noch den gibt es noch ich würde auch gerne an deiner tür kratzten
minigun michi 2 null hat subscribt twitch prime dankeschön
mach was mit kriegern macht er noch was da taucht doch jetzt überall auf der
welt rum was hätte die netzfreigabe für eine bandbreite kann man so videos in
vegas bar und ja geht das hängt davon ab wie schnell der netzwerk ist
hast du mal überlegt auf erwart mit roll cue wieder zu zocken ja habe ich
sogar gemacht auf dem ptr
wir brauchen mehr bettel viel drei gameplays bettel viel drei ist relativ
tot es gibt auf dem pc noch ein paar dämmer wenn peak rushserver ansonsten
muss ich mal gucken fucking pock gechillt im bett videos schneiden
haben wir das am tablet
dual mit katja krasavice genau das ist das ist natürlich die erste dual
partner partnerin die ich mir vorstelle wenn ich sage ich muss mit jemand anderem
was aufnehmen ich habe jetzt nicht irgendwie an leute
gedacht die gaming sachen machen das erste woran ich gedacht habe natürlich
katja krasavice ich weiß ich könnte den namen und ich weiß nicht mal wie man den
namen richtig ausspricht
ich fand super wenn du ein laber stilles video machen würde das ja da
wäre ich bestimmt noch genug machen
wir vermissen dich max der scham und die qualität deiner videos ist immer noch
top
ups irgendwie habe ich gerade nicht ausgeblendet
irgendwie dazu soll ich ich werde bestimmt mal irgendwas zum zug erzählen
aber es ist jetzt ja nicht so dass jeden tag irgendwie ein video machen kann
irgendwas zum zug erzählt aber es ist jetzt ja nicht so dass jeden tag irgendwas
total spannendes im zug passiert ich hatte übrigens noch eine gute
eine gute video idee ich wollte so eine ich wollte so ein paar sachen erzählen
ich weiß nicht wie ich das ich das nennen sollte irgendwie horror stories
aus dem support kann ich es nicht nennen weil es ist nicht wirklich support
wo ein paar abgedrehte sachen erzählen die ich so die letzten 12 13 jahre
it mäßig erlebt hat weil er war schon ein paar ziemlich beknackte sachen
drin und ich meine jetzt nicht dass ich meine schuhe hinter dem rack trockne
sondern wirklich ziemlich bescheuerte sachen
max alles fit ja alles huge fit big brain fit
deshalb habe ich mir die dark edition vorbestellt ich würde mir nie was
vorbestellen mehr ich verstehe dass ich mal muss ich euch mal fragen also chat
huge huge chat bestellt ihr euch games vor und wenn ja warum bestellt ihr euch
games vor ich persönlich bin der meinung games vorbestellen bringt nix weil das
was man also man bekommt das man bekommt das gleiche game wenn es raus ist und
heute ist es ja auch so ich muss nichts vorbestellen weil ich kann es einfach
downloaden am tag des releases die einzige sache wenn irgendjemand was
vorbestellt vielleicht wenn er irgendwie call of duty auf der konsole zwei tage
früher spielen will weil er klöck hat aber es lohnt sich eigentlich nicht es
lohnt sich aktuell überhaupt nicht mehr was vorzubestellen das einzige wo ich
mir noch vorbestellen vorstellen könnte was vorzubestellen ist wenn es
irgendwie eine super collectors special extreme edition ist solange es nicht so
übertrieben ist wie bei watch dogs als ich da noch einer dran erinnern kann ich
mein guckt euch die guckt euch die tabellen liste von von watch die die die
editions an die watch dog hatte jetzt kein witz so viele versions so viele
unterschiedliche version von watch dogs 1 gab es aber auch die schlimmste die
schlimmsten ausmaße die ich je gesehen habe von also wenn es jetzt sagen wir
mal die bringen jetzt irgendwie sagen wir sie würden jetzt irgendwie max pain 4
oder so rausbringen was ja eines meiner absolut lieblichen spiele serien ist und
man glaub es wäre wieder von remedy in max pain 4 und so bringen irgendwie eine
super special collectors edition raus mit irgendwie figuren aus teil 1 2 3 4
oder so und ich sag oder sieht so geil aus und es gibt da irgendwie limitiert
was von ok dann würde ich vorbestellen aber da würde ich ja nicht wirklich das
game vorbestellen sondern eigentlich hauptsächlich den content von der von
der special edition aber ansonsten finde ich lohnt sich
vorbestellen ich verstehe keinen sinn und selbst und selbst so sachen wie
nintendo spiele die ja die er sagt man macht selten die fans wirklich
enttäuschen ja nintendo ist ja da recht konstant also sprich wenn neues zell da
kommt und bis zeller fern kannst du eigentlich zeller vorbestellen gibt
nichts was dagegen spricht aber selbst da lohnt sich nicht weil du kannst
das spiel einfach am release tag runterladen also wozu wozu wozu ich
finde es lohnt sich nicht genau so viel zu so viel vorbestellen
zu dem ersten video waren sehr viele comments dabei die sich gefreut haben
dass ich wieder am start bin wie gesagt das freut mich auch immer wenn ich das sehe
ohne dass ich keine subs verpasst habe ob auch ich nicht
manchmal registrieren schüsse nicht du warst halt zweimal 100 prozent neben dem
spieler schon lustig jemand eigentlich zu spielen ich glaube nicht dass ich
ich weiß welche szene er meint aber ich war nicht neben dem spieler
guckt euch mal an guckt euch mal an ich zeige euch mal die zählen die szene die
er meint alles am anfang
ja pass mal auf sagt mal ob ich daneben war oder nicht jetzt ernsthaft guckt
euch das mal an und sagt ich bin daneben ich bin voll drauf und jetzt tschuss das
ist ja ich ziehe es ja nicht nach oben das ist ja der recoil von der waffe
das ist ja der recoil von der waffe der so springt
guck mal das ist voll drauf bäm
und jetzt zweiter schuss zweiter schuss zweiter schuss achtung na gut der zweit
der zweite schuss war gegen die gegen die brüstung das lasse ich mir gefallen
bei selbst der zweite schuss naja gut mach mal kurz slo mo rein ok
leute wir gucken uns das jetzt an wir gucken uns das acht slo mo in das
überhaupt playback speed und fünf moment das ist der falsche schuss
es klingt bisschen unanständig oder soll es ist gerade irgendwie kappa
pride und am tisch am start oder so so pass mal auf jetzt das ist nicht verzogen
das ist voll drauf guckt das ist voll drauf
bäm mach mal frame by family kann man so über übertreiben ich werde mehr geht
auch gar nicht ja custom mehr weniger geht nicht ein pixel zu weit vom kopf
ja weil die call of duty konsolen hitboxen auch so bekannt dafür sind dass
die pixel pixel genau sind also ich behaupte immer noch das war drauf wir
müssen jetzt aber auch nicht über analysieren ja die grundspiele sind in
den key stores teurer als vorwärts das stimmt aber ich kauf eh nichts mehr
über key stores ich habe ja ich habe ja jetzt kann ich ja sagen ich habe ja
keine vertraglichen verpflichtungen mehr dafür ich habe ja g2a nie promoted
weil ich g2a irgendwie so geil fand oder von dem von dem business modell
überzeugt war der einzige grund warum ich g2a promoted hab
ist weil sie ziemlich viel kohle bezahlt haben pro monat warum dieser namen hier
oft wird und ich darf und ich max fps zwei gründe erster grund weil ich den
account erstellt habe als ich überhaupt nicht daran gedacht habe selbst zu
streamen ich wollte nicht dass ich erkannt werde wenn ich in anderen
streams dämliches zeug spamme das war so der erste grund und der zweite grund
ist warum ich dabei geblieben bin ich meine ich könnte mich immer noch um
benennen ja ich habe den renames kann geht ich habe sogar den origine ich habe
sogar den max fps account ich könnte mich umbenennen aber ich finde es
eigentlich ganz gut weil es kommen manchmal die richtige deppen rüber die
mich irgendwann mal vor jahren geguckt haben und mich schon immer mal flamen
wollten tauchen dann hier im chat auf und ich
könnte mir vorstellen wenn ich hier heißt wie auf youtube gibt es davon noch
mehr so rum ist es lieber so rum kommen jetzt nämlich hauptsächlich die leute
dies dies interessiert die noch aktiv am start sind da kommt die wahrheit ans
licht ja naja ganz ehrlich jetzt war wie hätte der kabum gesagt hand aufs
herz denkt jemand wirklich leute promoten key shops oder solche lehnen
weil sie davon innerlich kommt voll überzeugt sind oder ist es nicht bei
allen irgendwie die kohle
also bei mir war es die kohle da kann ich sagen
woher hast du die emotes sound einpanne gibt es das soundport oder sowas das
habe ich selbst programmiert hier da ist das ja da ist da ist das mime board
ist der asp dort net core anwendung mit wpf für das für das overlay selbst
selbst gebastelt
wie viel hat sie zu 80 bezahlt weiß ich ob ich das jetzt groß an die clock
gehängt soll wobei scheiß drauf ich habe schon mal erzählt
lasst mal kurz in mich gehen
ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher was zum schluss gekriegt habe ich habe mit
denen auch ein paar mal hin und her verhandelt ich sag mal so ungefähr
1000 euro im monat so über den daumen gepalt plus minus affiliate ungefähr so
im dreh und das war für mich halt damals ziemlich gutes angebot ja ob ich sag
gut dafür mache ich auch sehr laut und erzählen ihr seid die geilsten ist mir
noch wurscht
ja das finde ich mit das finde ich auch übertrieben erschreibt hier grad in
zwischen erzählen die youtuber ja zwei minuten lang davon wie produkt ihr leben
verändert hat und wie sie nie wieder ohne auskommen ich finde es teilweise auch
extrem also total übertrieben was was bei manchen promotion geschichten abgeht
es gibt aber auch hersteller die haben da kein bock drauf na mario kart für ios
vorbestellt stimmt kommt ja demnächst auch hat scheine oder münzen geregnet ich
habe es ja gerade gesagt schau mal ein altes video vom kaboom können wir
irgendwann können wir am wochenende machen wir machen am wochenende immer
sonntags einen aufwach stream so ab ja wir haben schon um acht gestartet aber
hauptsächlich so um halb neun halb zehn rum teilweise bis 13 14 uhr da gucken
wir uns immer noch ein paar videos an und aktuelle sachen da können wir uns auch
mal kaboom dir angucken inwiefern sind key seiten fragwürdig jetzt ist
fragwürdig woher die keys kommen das ist so ein bisschen so ein bisschen wie die
leden die die microsoft oder windows keys für 1.50 verkaufen
wobei nee kann man nicht vergleichen es sind oft bei den microsoft keys sind auf
jeden fall quasi in ordentlich ausgestellte für diesen zweck keys bei
den game keys sind das teilweise promotion keys die irgendwo geleakt
wurden oder oder oder vermeintliche vermeintliche keys für vermeintliche
youtuber streamer oder sonst was da wird getrickst ohne ende ja mich wird nicht
wundern wenn da manche irgendwie manche code packs von irgendeinem lkw geklaut
werden oder so wird mich alles nicht wundern
allerdings man kann den key shops auch nicht den kompletten vorwurf machen
weil zumindest bei g2a ist es so dass es in marketplace ist also sprich nicht
g2a die die fragwürdigen keys verkauft sondern seller allerdings weiß das
g2a also kann mir keiner erzählen dass das g2a nicht weiß was es nicht weniger
fragwürdig macht
wir machen das jetzt weil wir müssen das erzählen wie i love cookies machen
jetzt einfach hier 10k beim pokern ausgeben das ist doch jetzt krasser
krasser da fedor fedor da ist doch jetzt krasser pokermann habe ich habe ich
irgendwo stoppt der mco hat mir das glaube ich erzählt als voll krasse poker
gut
progorn fragt setze gerade mein laptop für studium auf und bin mir unsicher auf
welches betriebssystem ich setzen soll linux fürs programmieren oder windows
weil du dafür auch alles bekommst ganz einfach das ist super einfach
mach so wie ich installiert hier windows und installiert in der linux vm ganz
einfach
vielleicht geht es jetzt aber warum ist das kaputt
warum habe ich ein programm geschrottet
du hast kreditkartenbetrug vergessen wenn es um das wenn zum key shops geht auch
das ja hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich sogar das bei irgendwelchen key shop
reseller
ne der ist heute rausgeflogen keine ahnung habe ich verfolgt aber ich weiß
dass jetzt der krasse pokermann ist fedor hat mit poker circa eine million
verdient dazu kam easy money easy life wobei man ja nie weiß ob das ob das alles
so stimmt immer na also bei generell bei werbung für irgendwelche
glücksspiel sachen wäre ich ich weiß dass poker nicht reines glücksspiel in
form von zumindest wenn man ein bisschen plan und über längere zeit macht nicht
vergleichbar ist mit dem druck auf dem automat rum aber bei allen die quasi
hypen dass sie mit mit irgendeiner form von glücksspiel millionär reich sonst
was gewonnen sind da wäre ich immer immer skeptisch
moin denkst du ein informatik studium nach der fisi ausbildung macht sinn oder
kommt man weiter wenn man die zeiten zertifikate berufserfahrung steckt
zertifikate kommt auf den laden an ich bin zertifikate sinnlos berufserfahrung
ist wichtig und es ist vor allem wichtig dass du dich in dem bereich auskennst
der ordentlich kohle bringt also wenn du wenn du ein bisschen windows oberfläche
klicken kannst ist das ganz nett werden auch leute gesucht aber die
wahnsinnige bezahlung wirste dafür nicht kriegen ein bisschen drauf an ja und die
die hauptsächliche frage ist eigentlich eher ob dir das das liegt also ob du
beispielsweise auf analytische sachen stehst ob du auf mathe stehst ob du ja
sowas dann ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt wenn du spaß dran hast oder
dich dafür interessiert das war zu probieren mit dem studium
halbe kotz zähne nach black ops 2 zu lifestyle casino gewechselt deswegen
verfolge ich da auch kaum noch ein jetzt den weg von winners 32 spiel auf
16 bin ich glaube nicht
was ist mit dem linux subsystem von winners ist auf einem guten weg fehlt
noch einiges vor allem kein ordentliches terminal unter winners
weil das nicht fehlen mit den fast passes dazu sage ich nichts
ich kenne die umfangreichere story davon ich war ja live dabei da sage ich
nichts zu kann nur sagen ist es nicht unbedingt alles immer so wie es auf den
ersten blick aussieht
ist transparent ok ok
ja kommens weiter komm ich habe den chat aufgeholt gut war face keine ahnung zu
im ersten video kam jetzt nicht mehr so viel interessantes außer halt wie gesagt
die ganze geschichte dass die leute freuen habe ich schon oft freut mich auch
wenn man das einer schreibt der beste gewichtete schuss ist bleibt bei der ak
headshot von cs go dieses geräusch bling das war nicht bling bling war
overwatch fack was macht was macht cs noch mal
overwatch hat bling gemacht cs macht so dieses genau doch das da macht viel zu
lange pausen zu wenig videos von dir für neue abos
feels bad man die map einfach awp india geklaut awp india ist das der
microsoft supporter cs spielt oder was ja sieht tatsächlich ähnlich aus
die ganzen mw2 to and to maps waren richtig schlecht hast du tipps für die
ihk abschlussprüfung anwaltungsentwicklung ja einfach alte
abschlussprüfung angucken easy ihk abschlussprüfung kann jeder schaffen
jeder sogar jeder der die ausbildung nicht gemacht hat kann ihk abschlussprüfung
schaffen ihk abschlussprüfung ist eigentlich wenn man es genau nimmt kein
irgendwie qualitätsmerkmal ich würde mich eher wundern wenn die leute zu gut
abgeschnitten haben dass die zu sehr zu sehr ihk style denken und man damit
nichts anfangen kann das waffengefühl ist ähnlich zu battle viel drei ich
weiß nicht ich weiß nicht ich finde die waffen haben sich in
battle viel drei eigentlich relativ leicht angefühlt die waffen in mw in
dem neuen modern war verfühlen sich schwer an
was ist intelligentes nachlassen gute frage wollte ich auch gerade fragen
was ist intelligentes nachladen du meinst dass man schneller nachlädt wenn
man leer geschossen hat oder was langsamer nachlädt wenn man leer
geschossen investierst du dein geld immobilien oder aktien also also alle
diese ganzen wirtschaftsgeschichten ist wirklich nicht meins allerdings muss ich
dazu sagen ich kann mir auch nicht mit angucken dass irgendwie mein geld darum
gammelt und nichts passiert in letzter zeit habe ich ein bisschen geld also
nicht wirklich kann man kann es eigentlich nicht investiert nennen ich
habe ein paar leuten geld geliehen zu ganz guten zinsen also wie nennt man das
so was privat darlehnen privat kredit oder so aber mit verdrag und und allem
was dazu gehört und die ersten zwei sachen sind auch schon zurückbezahlt
das hat sich gelohnt war fast schon ein bisschen hast schon ein bisschen
fast schon ein bisschen schlechtes gewissen bei dem zinssatz beim ersten
magst du mit dem baseball schläger beim geld abtreiben ich mache das anders wir
machen einen verdrag und wenn sich beispielsweise ein anderen auto kauft
was bei dem einen aber einer wollte ich gebraucht das auto kaufen kriege ich
halt den schein vom auto bis abbezahlt ich meine klar ich mache das auch nur
mit leuten die ich halt kennen es ist mit sicherheit nicht der weisheit letzter
schluss irgendwie aber für alles andere bin ich zu warum sollten die leute zu
dir gehen und nicht zur bank fliegt zum beispiel weil sein schufa eintrag haben
da einer hatte den schufa eintrag von von dem mobilfunkanbieter
da wollte sich geld leiten ist jetzt nicht ausgedacht ja muss man nämlich
davor sagen weil das übertrieben viel ist nicht ausgedacht wollte zur bank
sagt braucht geld für den autobanker sei gibt es nicht da ist er zu einem
anderen typ gegangen der halt auch an leute die von der bank nichts kriegen und
er wollte über drei jahre haltet euch fest 75 prozent 75 prozent also bei das
das ist das dürfte wahrscheinlich schon illegal
über drei jahre 75 prozent habe ich halt gesagt ob bei mir ist billiger
ich warte so mit leuten die ich kenne also ich verleihe keine ich verleihe
vielleicht nicht irgendwie großkohle an random leute aus dem chat auch nicht
wenn es cute chat ist dubi day twitch prime dankeschön
das ist nicht egal solange ich den kram versteuern ist da nichts illegal dran
also weil sie finden die 75 prozent nee ich glaube noch nicht ich habe das jetzt
nur gesagt mit dem illegal ich bin mir gar nicht mal so sicher ob das illegal
ist wenn das vorher klar ist dass allen beteiligten klar sind klar ist und man
sich im vollbesitz seiner geistigen kräfte befindet und das unterschreibt
glaube ich nicht dass das illegal ist es ist es ist ja auch nicht verboten
scheiße zu verkaufen wenn ich leute finde die scheiße
kaufen die e es gibt leute die verkaufen open office libra office gibt es gibt
leute die kaufen das pass auf falls ihr mir das nicht glaubt ebay
ups weiß nicht was ich da für die ebay adresse hatte ich lasse es mal lieber
ja libra office libra office libra office 5 euro
libra office starte 10 euro das sagt doch 15 euro weil es auf einem usb stick ist
für 15 euro kriegst du in china 20 usb sticks
noch die bosch die machen wir ausrufe zeichen beruf die frage kommt nämlich
dass ich habe versucht zu erklären
steig steigt auch ins gamer badewassergeschäft ein ich habe gehört bell
delphin wurde gebannt auf instagram das so stimmt das ich will jetzt nicht auf
die seite gucken weil weil monka tos
übrigens ich hätte noch ein thema am ende so zum outro aber es dauert noch
wir haben noch massig zeit wo ich mich noch mal richtig wo ich bin noch ein
bisschen aufregen kann drüber
natürlich zwei monate nice dankeschön gerade rechner aufgesetzt so ein geiles
gefühl weiß ich ich weiß ich nicht also ich finde nicht da muss man immer so
viel zeug neu einrichten ich habe mein windows seit fünf jahren
immer neu installiert oder irgendwie in dem dreh eben nicht mehr nicht stimmt
nicht auf die auf die m2 ssd habe ich neu installiert vor drei jahren
prings nice 263 leute hutsch was blöde frage wer ist denn alles von youtube
hier ok viele viele ja ich sehe viele ja weil sie schon interessant normalerweise
je nach je nach je nach thema das höchste was ich mal hatte an zuschauen war
glaube ich so um die haben wir so um die 300 bei den games kommen sachen immer
und ansonsten ist es irgendwie so so so maximal 180 so rum meinte ich soll ab
und zu mal ein paar ankündigungen auf youtube youtube posten
ich meine ich werde nicht jeden stream ankündigen fallen wenn es in den
programmier stream ist oder so das werden die meisten leute auf youtube nicht
nicht interessieren aber wenn wir irgendwas machen was was die leute auf
youtube interessieren könnte jetzt jetzt gehen die subs die die die
follower gehen ab follow spam
ich habe was übersehen der hummer hans hat abonniert habe ich das
übersehen oder habe ich das vor habe ich in hummer hans schon vorgelesen
hummer hans bist du noch am start
extra für den hummer hans hast du nicht dafür dafür schrumpft der chat eq
jetzt feels bad man hummer hans kurze it frage mein notebook hat einen kern
permanent zu 100 prozent ausgelastet im eidl
das kann ich eidl sein wenn das egal haf bin aus mehrmals 19 aber es geht nicht
weg hast du bin aus voll installen wenn aus 19 von der cd vom hersteller
wenn du es von der cd vom hersteller hast latin in ordentliches iso runter und
installieren auch mal neu
nicht viel spät man viel spät komplett neu formatiert ja gute frage dann
weiß ich auch nicht
also im ersten video war nicht so viel interessante comments drinnen aber es
hat mich motiviert dass so viele leute sich gefreut haben dass ich wieder am
start bin das finde ich auch also also dieser 2 was das 2 modus wirkt ein
bisschen wie als wollen sie auf das wollen sie ein bisschen auf rainbow 6 machen
der hummer hat sich habe ich habe es nicht so ernst genommen im taskman da
steht nur system es könnte sein dass wenn aus wenn aus erst mal ewig lange
updated das macht mir noch ganz gerne mal hast du es mal ein bisschen stehen
lassen ob das nicht weg geht nach einer zeit
wo ist das intro intros sind auf youtube nicht mal angesagt
zumindest nicht intros ganz vorne heute macht man entweder ein bisschen
preview und intro und man scheißt auf intro und labert gleich los weil gerade
die ersten zehn sekunden sind halt heutzutage enorm wichtig weil hat
keiner mehr wirklich lange videos guckt also also keiner keiner wirklich die
große aufmerksamkeit hat für leute machen das an und wenn du nicht die
ersten 20 30 sekunden was sagst was die leute geil finden machen die meistens
aus
der rückstoß in modern warfare ist bei einigen waffen nicht nicht ohne
der klang der waffen ist vergammt gut gelogen ok kann ich nicht einschätzen
aber ich glaube an den klang der waffen aus bed company 2 mit war tapes kommt
kein spiel in extra zeit oder je ran bester bester klang überhaupt sollte
nicht drei stunden dauern nenene nur sollte es sollte es nicht ganz immer von
handwindows update machen nach dem installieren
was von handwindows update an lass ihn auf zum neuesten aktualisieren und mach
mal falls die probleme weiter bestehen da thema vom hersteller die die die das
das den ihr jeweilige service tool oder was sie da haben runter und machen wir
bios update oder ist ja kein bios mehr ist ja efe update wusste die eigentlich
das aktuelle efe ist also die aktuellen uefi sachen die auf mainboard hat was
da alles drin ist die dinge haben mittlerweile einen kompletten usb stack
einen kompletten tcp stack teilweise kompletten bluetooth stack und was weiß
ich noch alles so ein efe ist mittlerweile glaube ich
irgendwie was was habe ich letztens gelesen an die eine million code
zeilen
ich meine wer hat sich nicht schon immer mal bewundert und gesagt früher als er
in diesem alten bios war mit dem blauen hintergrund wer hat er nicht
damals schon immer gesagt alter hätte ich jetzt mal einen tcp stack im bios
ach so das ist na moment wenn das ein happi wenn das ein fertiger happi oben
ist dann sollte so was wirklich nicht passieren
ey max dass es dich noch gibt ja mich gibt's auf twitch auf twitch gibt's mich
schon zwei jahre und sogar relativ regelmäßig
aber auf youtube in letzter zeit wenig da hast recht langzeitmotivation der
langzeitmotivation ist der modern warfare 2 und 2 modus auf jeden fall
nicht im rs ich gebe mal zum zweiten video
warum macht man die ins uefi eigentlich keinen windows linux downloader rein
dann bräuchte man keine bootsticks mehr
keine ahnung die idee ist doch keiner gekommen
next next level play kann man dann nicht über den tcp stack auch an pios update
ja ja klar mir ist schon klar warum der bluetooth usb und und tcp ip drinne
sind logisch das ist das alle einbegabegeräte im bios funktionieren
keiner hat mehr bock mit ps2 tastatur anzuschließen nur fürs bios oder eine
usb tastatur oder nein vorbei nichts usb ps2 will keiner ps2 es wird auch
keiner mehr mit diskette den bios update machen schon klar die leute wollen ins
bier das will auch keiner mehr eine 640 x 480 auflösung im bios haben die leute
wollen da heute am besten noch maus supporten alles
hänse dich mit routern aus sorry router ja wir haben ja viele cisco fans im chat
das weiß ich ja aber ich persönlich finde mag immer noch eher die
aussprache router kennst du dich mit routern aus wollte von einer fritz box 736
2 sl auf eine 400 4040 umsteigen habe eine 500er ich habe keine ahnung ich
weiß noch nicht mal was die dinge unterscheidet überhaupt aber ja ich
kenne mich mit routern aus aber ich habe es am anfang gesagt
fritz box ist ziemlich schlechter router und fritz fritz box ist ein sehr gutes
multifunktionsgerät die routing funktionen von der fritz box sind doch
äußerst rudimentär
aber ich weiß die meisten leute sagen router die coolen leute sagen
routimentär genau hast du eigentlich noch was mit den alten youtube hasen wie
kaboom commander krieger und im friseur zu nehmen mit dem friseur e mit dem
friseur e den kenne ich auch schon vorher mit dem kaboom ganz ganz selten mit dem
krieger gar nicht mehr letztens erst mit dem m com wieder
gelabert mit dem m com alter m core ich mein ich meine ich komme lege hände
m com das fand ich übrigens sehr nice falls noch da ist soll auf jeden fall was
aufnehmen wieder mal jetzt demnächst solange ich noch
motivation habe
weißt du warum kaboom nichts mehr bringt das fragt er sich selbst das fragt er
sich selbst also so wirklich abgeschlossen hat er hat er hat er
eigentlich nie mit dem mit dem youtube thema ja aber also ich glaube es ist so
ein bisschen der wird einfach seinem eigenen anspruch an die video qualität
nicht so richtig gerecht ob max damals auf dem abo treffen von commander krieger
war ich bei den einfach nur bei den jahr danach gab es noch zwei drei videos mit
hier oder rein felsgelände mit dem tier habe ich vor vor der ganzen weile mal
weiß gar nicht ob wir gelabert haben oder was wir kurz geschrieben haben aber
nicht wirklich nehmen wie findest du black desert es ist nicht mein game
ich weiß da fabian kreiner das rauf und runter also der friseur aber es ist nicht
mein gelb
kaboom war mit den videos einer zeit voraus ich finde es gibt heute keine
videos in dieser in dieser richtung es gibt zwar viel viel mehr videos die gut
editiert sind und viel viel mehr videos die auch mehr mehr wie sagt man so
production value haben ja aber production value plus kompetenter
inhalt in der tiefe gibt es eigentlich nicht
die maps sehen aus wie billiges teamwork workshops für cs ja genau das
denke ich über die aktuellen modern warfare maps auch
das mit den maps ist schon ein kleines problem gerade in einem solchen modus
würden sich lustige gimmicks anbilden schalter falltür oder ja finde ich auch
ein bisschen taktischer könnte man das ganze machen
vermisst mega die black ops einstarten karten wie summit jungle weiblich
männlich diverse an neu etc das war schon nice hörst du immer noch metal und
falls ja welche bands hörst du am liebsten ja klar immer noch also
aktuell was ich was ich extrem nice finde ist ist fast schon so wie nicht
wirklich gehyped sind eigentlich ziemlich bekannt was ich übelst was mir
übelst gut fällt ist das hier das findet das gefällt mir ist gut
jutsch nice es ist halt power metal das finde ich cool also vor allem dieses
album das hat wirklich ohrwurm nach ohrwurm und ist bei amazon unlimited
music dabei power metal beste haben wir uns mal eins anhören nebenbei oder
verschreck ich oder verschreck ich euch mit mit power metal
ok kommen wir auf youtube was gibt
so in die richtung wie trankenfoss ja genau genau
wir gucken uns aber nicht das video an
die headbanging action
übelst nice also ist genau mein geschmack
also der refrain ist auch übelst nice kann ich nur empfehlen leute kann ich
nur empfehlen beste das war musik kontrast hier
wie findest du rammstein ist nicht meins ich finde auch die rammstein texte
übelst cringe teilweise nicht so sehr von der aussage diese manchmal haben das
ist halt absichtlich dass er da ein bisschen kontroverse dinge erzählen
aber wie die wie die sauer gedichtet sind die die rammstein texte das ist das
da zieht sich die sachen zusammen
du musst direkt hammer fall lasst hammer fall das ist auch nice ja
hervor kann man auch empfehlen wie findest du sabaton auch gut
wobei bei sabaton wenig mit a ja ja zu tun hat eigentlich null sabaton ist
eigentlich eher was für zweite weltkrieg shooter da wird da passt das gut
was ist das zelda lesezeichen in der seite
das ist der zelda 20 20 jahre 20 jahre zelda orchester soundtrack allerdings
den den gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr beste beste beste beste sache ist immer
noch der her was was
alter nintendo das ist immer noch beste nintendo sound ever
genau
Ttitettetetettetetet shed pegar
okay trotzdem
1 ± 2 3
1 ± 2 4
Übrigens wisst ihr, woran man merkt, dass Black Ops 1 eine andere Zeit war?
Bei WMD hat zu Black Ops 1 Zeiten noch kein Mensch an weiblich-männlich-divers gedacht,
sondern es haben alle an Weapons of Mass Destruction gedacht.
Mittlerweile ist was anders.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, wobei, ach nee, ich wollte mich da gar nicht drüber aufringen.
Ich hab heute Morgen News gelesen, dass eine PHP-Konferenz abgesagt wurde,
weil nicht genügend weibliche Sprecher am Start waren.
What the fuck?
Als geht's bei einer IT-Konferenz irgendwie...
Das geht doch nicht nur um, wer die Vorträge hält, sondern was der Inhalt der Vorträge ist.
Aber im Jahr 2019 ist alles nicht mehr so normal im Kopf, hab ich das Gefühl, was das anbelangt.
Ich bin ja wirklich schon immer...
Ich mein, ich hab Videos gemacht mit Mädels, die Sachen spielen auf YouTube,
bevor diese ganze Geschichte überhaupt im Trend war.
Also ich bin jemand, der prinzipiell sehr davon überzeugt ist, dass alle Leute das machen sollen,
oder dass man ihnen die Möglichkeit geben sollte, das zu machen, was sie sich wünschen zu tun.
Allerdings, man kann es auch nicht erzwingen.
Wenn jemand nicht will, dann hat es keinen Sinn zu sagen, du musst.
Das wäre wieder genau das Gegenteil davon.
Du sollst wirklich jedem das ermöglichen, im Rahmen natürlich,
es können nicht alle Astronaut werden, das zu tun, was er machen soll.
Aber du kannst nicht erzwingen, dass auf einer IT-Konferenz,
wo sich eine Frau von 250 Leuten beworben hat, die Hälfte Frauen sind.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich bin dafür, wenn sich da Frauen bewerben,
dann sollte man selbstverständlich auch Frauen einladen, wenn der Talk gut ist.
Aber wenn sich keine Frauen bewerben, wo sollen die denn herkommen?
Egal, da hab ich keinen Bock jetzt drauf.
Da hab ich keinen Nerv drauf, das Thema geht mir voll auf den Sack.
Zumal kein Mensch mehr irgendwie halbwegs normal im Kopf ist,
über die Sachen diskutieren kann, sondern entweder bist du übelst zu Spaß,
weil sie sagen, du bist dagegen, du bist hier irgendwie Rassist, Nazi, sonst was.
Bloß weil du halt nicht zu allem Jahr und Abend sagst.
Oder aber, du musst übelst auf divers machen.
Was dazwischen ist heute irgendwie kein Platz mehr.
Und ihr wisst, dass ich bei allen Sachen eigentlich, oder ich bin bei den meisten Sachen,
ich bin ganz selten wirklich extrem für was oder extrem gegen was.
Aber da ist heute kein Platz mehr.
Du bist heute entweder auf der einen Seite oder auf der anderen Seite.
Die Seite in der Mitte, das in der Mitte juckt kein Mensch mehr heute.
Nacho Libre, die haben ja nicht deswegen abgesagt.
Du musst dir das mal durchlesen.
Die haben abgesagt, die Konferenz wurde abgesagt,
weil zwei männliche Speaker sich übertrieben empört haben,
dass es keine weiblichen Speaker gibt.
Und deswegen ihre Teilnahme abgesagt haben.
Und das waren halt zwei, zwei, drei, wie nennt man das?
Headline Speaker, weswegen die Leute quasi Konferenztickets gekauft haben.
Und nachdem die abgesagt haben, hat der Veranstalter gesagt,
hat finanziell keinen Sinn mehr, kauft keine Tickets.
Ich mein, wenn du deine drei größten Speaker,
die zwei Talks haben an irgendwie nem Wochenende verlierst,
das wofür die Leute hingehen,
dann kann ich nachvollziehen, dass man das absagt.
Dieses Thema finde ich so unglaublich bescheuert,
vor allem wie beknackt darüber diskutiert wird.
Man kann da auch gar nicht normal drüber diskutieren.
Entweder bist du dafür oder du bist dagegen.
So irgendwie...
So Grauzone gibt es nicht.
Wobei die Welt ist halt einfach Grauzone.
Die echte Welt ist Grauzone.
Es gibt selten 100% und 0%.
Es gibt öfters 99 und 1%.
Aber 100% und 0% gibt es so gut wie bei nix.
Oder wie es da Sebaro sagt, es ist halt nicht schwarz und weiß.
Fast nix.
Deswegen finde ich die Diskussion wieder drüber diskutiert,
weil total beknackt.
Aber wir gucken uns weiter, Comments.
Der Max Sox ist gefollowed.
Den Namen finde ich sehr ansprechend.
Prime1996.
Das ist jetzt aber schon Next Level hier, oder?
Dass Prime nicht mit Prime abonniert.
Was soll ich denn jetzt für ein Sound machen?
Soll ich jetzt...
Machen?
Oder soll ich nur?
Was soll ich machen?
Das überfordert mein Hirn gerade massiv.
Wir machen einfach beides.
Samusprime.
Das hört sich auch beknackt an, oder?
Okay, ist gut jetzt.
Damals inspiriert von dir, weil man sieht das sofort am Namen.
Damage.
Oder vielleicht auch Damage.
Oder wenn es französisch ist, Damage.
Wahrscheinlich aber eher Damage.
Abonniert Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Nice.
100 Bits, Dankeschön.
Eine Million Bits.
Jetzt kann ich auch Poker spielen.
Warum sind die...
Ach so, weil ich so klein gemacht habe.
Es war nur der Name frei 2.
Abonniert Twitch Prime.
Samusprime.
Pok.
Nice.
Und der Aero-X ist auch am Start.
Der Aero-X ist 2 Monate am Start.
Dafür gibt es 360 Noscope.
360 Noscope.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs.
Heute geht es ab.
Heute sind die Subs hier.
Es lohnt sich richtig, den Gramm auf YouTube anzukündigen.
Es ist Huge Sellout Potential.
Hab ich euch eigentlich schon erklärt, wie toll es ist,
wenn man Twitch Prime hat, was man da machen kann mit?
Dass der Sellout dich krass überzeugt hat.
Klar, Sellout zieht immer.
Max, danke, dass du meine Kindheit Jugend so begleitet hast.
Ich freue mich jedes Mal, wenn du ein Video hochlätst.
Bitte bleib uns noch etwas auf YouTube und Twitch erhalten.
Das ist nett.
Ich hoffe, du bleibst uns auch noch erhalten.
Sowohl auf YouTube als auch auf Twitch.
Ich muss übrigens mal was sagen.
Ganz ohne zu schleimen, so nach dem Motto,
ich habe die besten Subscriber, Prime Like, Subscribe, Blah,
und Twitch Prime und Donate und Patreon und so.
Ganz unabhängig davon.
Ich muss echt sagen,
ich weiß, dass mittlerweile viel mehr zu schätzen,
wie viele Leute sich freiwillig
und gerne meine geistigen Ergüsse auf YouTube angucken
oder auch auf Twitch, wie früher.
Früher konnte ich das gar nicht so richtig einschätzen.
Da habe ich gedacht, na gut,
Leute gucken halt gerne Call of Duty.
Mittlerweile habe ich kapiert,
was die Leute schon auch gerne Call of Duty und gerne Battlefield
oder irgendwelche anderen Games gucken,
aber dass die Leute tatsächlich hauptsächlich gerne
wegen mir sich den Kram angucken,
was ja für mich prinzipiell komplett...
Das habe ich früher gar nicht so kapiert.
Ich habe mir gerade das neue Linus Tech Tips Videos angesehen
und haben gesagt, dass Netflix VPN anbietet.
Das macht Netflix schon lange.
Mit dem Max, der seit hierher eine genderfreundliche Begrüßung hat.
Was? Genderfeindliche? Warum?
Da müsste ich sagen, hallo Jungs und Mädels,
hier ist der Max.
Da müsste ich sagen, hallo Jungs und Mädels
und jetzt muss ich erstmal 45 Sachen aufzählen,
dass sich jeder angesprochen fühlt.
Hallo MWD.
Nee, nee, ich bleibe bei meiner Begrüßung.
Das Schlimme ist, dass sowas heute von vielen
schon wieder fast als halb Nazi gedeutet wird.
Einfach eine Begrüßung, die ich seit 10 Jahren habe.
Nach einer halben Stunde Resub, Joke Gaming, Dankeschön.
Twitch App auf Mobile ist grausam, aber sie ist besser geworden.
Ja, es ist besser geworden.
Hazelwood PG, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, nice.
Samus Climber, nice.
Panzer, zwei Monate, Dankeschön, nice.
Samus Climber, Hypers.
Ich gehe jetzt aber ab.
Moin, Panzer.
Und faktisch gibt es eben nur das Thema,
da gehe ich jetzt nicht im Stream drauf ein.
Da sei nichts zu.
Kennst du Flutter? Wenn ja, wo findest du es?
Ich finde Flutter geht eindeutig in die richtige Richtung
als Cross-Platform GUI-Framework.
Bits? Wir haben einen Bits-Sound, ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
100 Bits?
Lord of my Gurke.
Wie darf man das verstehen?
Ja, danke für die 100 Bits.
Huge, ein Euro.
Das ist echt ein Euro.
Wir nähern uns der Million,
dass ich Poker-Profi werden kann.
Was ist das für ein ekliges Emote?
Eine Tomate.
Snakery Twitch Prime, danke.
Also ich hatte ja gesagt,
Face Reveal bei 1.000.000 Abos,
weil das eh nix wird.
1.000 Subs ist ein Ziel, das ist machbar.
Das ist ganz schön viel für die aktuelle Sache,
aber das ist machbar irgendwo noch,
wogegen 1.000.000 Abos nicht machbar sind.
Also ich würde sagen, bei 2.000 Subs,
bei 2.000 Subs würde ich es machen.
Es hat voll den Sell-Out-Stand.
Bei 2.000 Subs würde ich es machen,
aber bei 2.000 Subs schaffen wir nix.
So einfach können wir es natürlich nicht machen.
Nicht einfach nur 2.000 Subs,
sondern es müssen auch 2.000 konstante Subs sein.
Also weil mit 2.000 Subs hätte ich nämlich endlich,
wie sage ich das jetzt am besten,
hätte ich so viel Sell-Out gemacht,
bis ich 2.000 Subs habe,
die ich wirklich rentieren würde.
Also sollte ich wirklich mal, ohne Scheiß,
sollte ich das irgendwie mal hinkriegen,
2.000 Subs zu bekommen
und ich bin dann auch aktiv auf YouTube und sonst was,
und das über eine ganze Weile,
dann hätte ich erstmal keine Geldprobleme mehr.
Hätte ich da manche Sachen weniger Probleme, ja.
Also allgemein ist es.
Also ich sag's nochmal, ohne Scheiß,
das ärgert mich auch ein bisschen bei anderen Streams,
wenn ich sehe, wenn ich mir das angucke,
ist es egal wo, aber wenn ich mir Streams angucke,
wo halt wirklich verdammt junge Leute zugucken,
die dann quasi ihr letztes, ihr letzte Kohle,
diese vielleicht sich irgendwie in den Sommerferien verdient haben,
weil sie beim Nachbarn irgendwie
irgendwie Hecke geschnitten haben,
wenn die diese Kohle PayPal donaten an einen großen Streamer.
Da blutet mir irgendwie so immer das Herz bei, ja.
Das find ich total bescheuert.
Die Leute sollen ihr Geld behalten
und das für was sinnvolles für sich selbst ausgeben.
Das brauchen die Leute nicht so dringend wie sie selbst.
Also ich mein, guck mal, wenn man sich jetzt irgendwie anguckt,
lass es mal, lass es mal in den Excuses sein
oder Montana Black oder so.
Die bekommen so viele Spenden,
da muss man nicht seine letzten 5 Euro spenden,
wenn man sie selbst besser gebrauchen könnte.
Ich mein, ich will mich nicht beschweren,
wenn mich einer subbt oder so.
Ich find das super, ja.
Und ich weiß, dass ich halt auch viele Leute hab,
die eben nicht 12 in ihre letzten 5 Euro spenden Taschengeld.
Geht auch lieber die letzten 5 Euro bei mir rein, Sam,
weil der letzte Song, das ist doch irgendwie so eine Playlist.
Beautiful Study Music.
Der Donate-Button ist weg, weil geht nicht.
Das ist kaputt.
Ich hatte eine Einblendung für Donations
und Tippy Stream hat es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Und deswegen hab ich den Donation-Button entfernt,
damit Tippy Stream wieder funktioniert.
Warum nicht Steamlabs?
Ich bin mir gar nicht...
Also Steamlabs hab ich ja für den Rest.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher.
Ich glaub, Tippy Stream hatte keine Gebühren
und hatte weniger Gebühren als Steamlabs.
Ich glaub, das war der Grund.
Das hatte einen Grund,
warum ich Tippy Stream genommen hab damals.
Kennst du die Ubiquiti-Network? Klar.
Übernehmen anscheinend die WLAN-Ausstrahlung für Router
und das bis zu 100 Meter je nach Modell.
Kannst du die auf Amazon machen?
Ich hab 2 Ubiquiti Access Points
und ein Ubiquiti 10-Gigabit-Switch.
Es kann letztendlich...
Es kann jeder sappen, wer ihn will.
Ich hab's ja vorhin gesagt.
Wenn's an mir geht, macht jeder, was er will.
Ich hab aber das Gefühl, dass ich manchmal,
vor allem besonders junge Leute,
verpflichtet fühlen, quasi,
das wenige Geld, was sie haben, zu donaten,
dass sie irgendwie dazugehören.
Und das ist eigentlich ein Gefühl,
das muss man nicht haben.
Man muss nicht das Gefühl haben,
man würde sich hier kostenlos entertainen lassen
und würde nichts dafür bezahlen.
Das ist plötzlich...
Man muss auch nicht donaten.
Man muss nichts spenden.
Man muss keine Bits donaten.
Auch bei mir nicht.
Nur um das Gefühl zu haben,
man möchte irgendwie dazugehören.
Ja, ich find's toll,
für jeden dazuguckt.
Ich freu mich,
über jeden dazuguckt.
Natürlich freu ich mich auch,
wenn einer abonniert,
wenn einer was donätet,
wenn einer Bits spendet.
Klar, natürlich.
Keine Frage.
Oh nein, 4,90.
Dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Das war jetzt negativ sell-out, oder?
Das war jetzt negativ sell-out gerade.
Also, ich hab vorher gesell-outet mit,
ihr sollt mich Amazon Prime subscriben,
und jetzt hab ich erzählt,
wann man nicht subscriben soll.
Also bei der Gelegenheit
wollte ich das Ganze nochmal erwähnen.
Wenn ihr einen Twitch Prime-Account habt,
besser gesagt,
wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime-Account habt,
könnt ihr das Ganze mit Twitch verbinden
zu einem Twitch Prime-Account,
und ihr könnt damit kostenlos
einen Streamer eurer Wahl
mit einem Tier-One-Sub unterstützen.
Das ist eine ganz normale Subscription.
Gibt alle Emotes dafür,
die der Streamer hat.
Wir haben übrigens auch seit heute
neue Emotes.
Kostet euch nix,
und der Streamer bekommt alle Vorteile davon,
die er von einem normalen Sub hatte.
Und ihr natürlich auch,
was Emotes und Sub-Batches
und sowas angeht.
Also, das ist kein schlechter Deal,
wenn man eh Amazon Prime hat.
Ups.
Sonst haben wir erstmal
noch eine schöne Runde Sellout gemacht.
Ich weiß,
viele mochten World War II nicht.
Aber für mich war das das perfekte Beispiel
für das, was du im Video erzählen hast.
Das Spiel hat bis Dezember
eine Menge Spaß gemacht,
und dann ging es los.
Jede Woche neue OP-Waffen nehmen.
Okay, wusste ich gar nicht,
dass es in World War II so schlimm war.
Okay.
Also, wo es richtig schlimm war,
ist Black Ops 4.
Mit ihren Black Market Supply Drops
und OP 0,2 Sekunden Double Kill-Waffen und Gedöns.
Ja, mir.
Simpsons Dude.
Zwei Monate
bis zu dem zweiten fortlaufenden Monat.
Huge.
Big Brain.
IQ vom Chat steigt weiter heute.
Bei so vielen Subs.
Und wen haben wir noch?
Tectonic.
Twitch Prime.
Tectonic, bist du nicht schon im zweiten Monat?
Nee, kommt der Name schon wie bekannt vor.
Kommt der Name.
Aber vielleicht bringe ich es durcheinander
mit jemand, der ähnlich heißt.
Sind schon über 200 Leute auf dem Discord.
Ja, übrigens Leute, wir haben Discord.
Haben auf YouTube damals ganz viele Leute gefragt.
Mittlerweile haben wir Discord.
Ausrufezeichen Discord.
Wir haben Channels für Technik-Kram,
Programmier-Kram, Heim-Automatisierung
und Sebaros privates Archiv.
Nennen wir es mal so.
Eins vor Drohne quasi.
Quasi, ja.
Sparta.
Trauma.
Twitch Prime, nice, danke.
Der Chat-IQ heute, der ist schon so hoch,
den kann man gar nicht mal darstellen
in irgendwelchen Emotes.
Selbst mag ich finde, der Boss ist BX7.
Ich finde mega, dass du momentan so aktiv bist.
Ich hoffe, das bleibt auch so.
Also ich bin motiviert.
Mal gucken, wie lange das hält.
Ich muss, das Wichtigste ist, Leute, ohne Scheiß,
da müsst ihr mich unterstützen bei,
ich weiß nicht genau wie,
aber da müsst ihr mich echt unterstützen bei.
Die ersten zwei Wochen,
ich muss die ersten zwei Wochen durchhalten.
Weil die ersten zwei Wochen dauert es immer,
bis YouTube sich wieder eingekriegt hat.
Bis YouTube alle inaktiven Subs aufgeräumt hat.
Bis YouTube Algorithmus wieder gecheckt hat,
dass man aktiv ist.
14 Tage, die ersten 14 Tage ist das Kritische.
Weil die ersten 14 Tage kann ich
die besten Videos vom besten hochladen
und ich werde auf keinen grünen Zweig
bei neuen Abos kommen.
Das ist jedes Mal so,
wenn du neu anfängst bei YouTube.
Das dauert immer ungefähr 14 Tage,
bis es konstant nach oben geht.
Also was Abozahlen angeht.
Also ihr müsst mich,
ich meine nicht,
dass ihr Subscriben müsst.
Weil in irgendeiner Form
brauche ich da eure volle Energy,
dass ich das 14 Tage durchhalte alles.
Warum kopierst du die ganze Zeit Buchstaben?
Dazu gibt es einen Clip.
Ausrufzeichen 1.
Ich gucke mir den Clip jetzt mal selbst an,
weil ich habe keine Ahnung mehr,
was ich da überhaupt erzählt habe.
Die volle Q-Chat-Energie.
Also was habe ich denn selbst mal erzählt,
warum ich immer Buchstaben kopiere?
Paste so und dann Cutte.
Ups.
Und dann auscutte
oder auch was ich ganz gerne mache,
irgendwas rechts anklicken
und dann auf Copy und so.
Das ist einfach, einfach Tick von mir.
Richtig.
So hier, sowas in der Richtung.
Das hat nichts, nichts, nichts zu sagen.
Und ich glaube, das liegt daran,
weil ich mir das zu Zeiten angewöhnt habe,
wo man noch viel ICQ-Text-Nachrichten
geschickt hat.
Und ich habe sehr viel ICQ-Text-Nachrichten
immer, immer Teile von Copy pasted.
Wenn man also Sachen,
die sich wiederholt haben und so.
Und da hatte ich immer Schiss,
dass ich aus versehen dem
oder der falschen, wie auch immer,
dann außerdem die falsche Nachricht schicke.
Ja, stimmt, genau.
Was ich, wenn ich über einen geflamet habe,
wollte ich dem noch etwas sagen.
Was weiß ich, wenn ich über einen geflamet habe,
wollte ich dem das nicht gerade schicken.
Ich erinnere mich wieder,
dass ich das gesagt habe.
Ja, richtig, das stimmt auch,
was ich gesagt habe.
Deswegen habe ich mir angewöhnt,
mein Clipboard irgendwie leer zu machen.
Aber eigentlich,
komplett den Schwachsinn.
Richtig, Max.
Eigentlich ist es Schwachsinn,
aber machs trotzdem.
Das ist die Erklärung dazu,
warum ich immer irgendwelche Sachen kopiere.
Wupplull.
Moment, warum, warum habe ich Wupp,
warum habe ich Wupplull überhaupt nicht
in meinem, in meinem Board drinnen?
Moment.
Wupplull.
Oh nee.
Ich habe mein eigenes Emote nicht mehr.
Also ist ja gar nicht so wirklich mein Emote.
Das habe ich mir, das habe ich mir kopiert
und Pixel abgeändert, ja.
Aber ich habe es nicht mehr.
Wo habe ich es denn hin?
Wupplull, Wupplull ist weg.
Es gibt doch so eine, warte mal, Twitch Emotes.
Da gibt es doch so eine Seite,
die das alles, die das alles hat.
Twitch Emotes.
Ja, geh mal fort.
Wupplulls.
Channel not found.
Fuck.
Und Wuppold ist ja auch nicht drinnen.
Old.
Wuppold.
Fuck.
Okay, da habe ich die auf dem anderen Account.
Holyship hat gerade nicht auf dem 7-Grupp-Bot
Confused als 2-Max gesprochen.
Ja, kann ich verstehen, weil man nicht zuguckt.
Ja, so sieht übrigens die Oberfläche aus von diesem,
von diesem Meme Sound Einplan Board.
Haben wir auch teilweise im Stream programmiert.
Ist allerdings schon eineinhalb Jahre oder so her.
Warum habe ich meine, ich habe die eine Katze drin.
Warum habe ich die andere Katze nicht auch drin?
Na, was auch immer.
Holgras dich auf Twitch zu finden.
Hab dich geschaut mit 13.
Heute bin ich 20.
Genau das Thema hatten wir vor einer halben Stunde.
Das ist unglaublich, wie viele Leute damals irgendwie 12, 13 waren.
Heute 20, 21.
Samolond, das kannst du dir nicht erzählen.
Die gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich hatte so ein bisschen Pech mit meinen letzten zwei Katzen.
Die waren aber schon alle alt.
Die waren schon alle alt.
Chico, Chico ist auch alt.
Aber Chico ist nicht ganz so alt.
Chico ist, Chico ist glaube ich 9, 9 oder 10.
Die erste war, die erste war glaube ich, die erste war 14, 15.
Und Barbie war, die hieß wirklich Barbie, die andere.
Die habe ich nicht so genannt.
Das haben sich die Vorbesitzer ausgedacht.
Barbie, ich würde meine Katze normalerweise nie Barbie nennen.
Barbie war auch irgendwie 11, 12.
Wann kommt Klo und Aufzug Update?
Also Klo gibt es nichts Neues und Aufzug ist ja weg, weil Dach isoliert.
Chico geht es gut.
Chico ist voll zufrieden.
Voll zufriedene Katze.
5000 Euro Amazon Shopping.
Reddit hat gerade ein Problem.
Warum wohl?
Erst einmal, erst einmal die Rolex, erst einmal die Rolex gekauft, Rolex bestellt.
Letztes Streamausschnitt gesehen, wo sie sich irgendwie Rolex-Uren für 55k oder so angeguckt haben.
75k angeguckt haben.
Immerhin gönnt sich ja sonst nichts.
War so eine kleine Rolex nebenbei.
Easy, easy as fuck.
Kein Ding.
By the way kommt das Staubsauger-Update-Video.
Ach ja, stimmt Leute.
Also es ist jetzt 21 Uhr.
Ich habe es euch ja versprochen.
Ich wollte euch ja mal den Staubsauger zeigen für alle, die über YouTube kommen.
Die Leute, die hier aus dem Chat da sind, die kennen das ja schon.
Den habe ich ja schon mal gezeigt.
Ich wollte euch ja das Webinterface, den Webinterface vom Staubsauger zeigen.
Ja.
Das ist das Webinterface vom Staubsauger.
Die, oh, die Map ist kaputt.
Die Map ist kaputt.
Sonst, warum ist die Map kaputt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Also zumindest ist es dieser Staubsauger hier.
IP League, oh ja, MonkaS, Hexor am Start.
Der Sebaro wieder.
Erst wird Fappy Bird gespielt und jetzt ist es der Robocock.
Ja, also das Ding ist, finde ich, der beste Staubsauger-Roboter.
Den es zurzeit gibt preisleistungsmäßig, wenn er im Angebot ist.
Und die Dinger sind recht oft im Angebot für bis zu 300, 320.
Also wenn ihr den irgendwo mal für 320 seht oder für 280 sogar, das ist wahrscheinlich ein anderer.
Also 280 ist ein Megapreis.
280 ist ein Megapreis.
Mal gucken, das ist bestimmt Fake News, dass das...
Aha, siehste, sag ich doch Fake.
Also wenn ihr ihn für 320 seht, das ist der beste Staubsauger-Roboter, den ihr euch holen könnt.
Erstens ist die Performance als Staubsauger-Roboter gut.
Der hat den extra Teppich, Teppich, ich zeige euch das gleich, Teppich-Modus,
nur mal, dass ihr das Ding gesehen habt. Also der Staubsauger-Roboter sieht super.
Allerdings, das große Problem ist, warum ich ihn nicht empfehlen kann,
wenn man technisch nicht so versiert ist, ist, der funktioniert halt nur mit der offiziellen App.
Und die offizielle App ist halt mit Cloud, mit Cloud in China.
Also sprich, wer damit keine Probleme hat, seinen Grundriss in die Cloud nach China zu übertragen,
für den ist das nicht so ein Problem. Was für mich ein Problem ist,
erstens meinen Grundriss und Daten in die China-Cloud zu übertragen,
mein WLAN-Passwort und alles, ja, ich glaube es geht los.
Was für mich ein Problem ist, ich finde es bescheuert, dass mein Staubsauger nicht geht,
sollte ich kein Internet haben oder die China-Cloud nicht erreichbar sein.
Es ist komplett hirnrissig, einen Staubsauger nicht funktionsfähig zu haben,
sollte das Internet weg sein.
Deswegen wird das Ding geflasht, deswegen habe ich das Ding geflasht
und geflasht ist das der wirklich ohne Scheiße, der preisleistungsmäßig unschlagbar beste Staubsauger-Roboter,
den ihr euch vorstellen könnt. Webinterface sieht folgendermaßen aus,
also hier sieht man eigentlich den Grundriss normalerweise, ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht oder so,
hier sieht man einen Grundriss von meinem Wohnzimmer gerade,
der hat so eine Laser oben drauf, das scannt da die Räume
und da kann man jetzt Zonen definieren,
z.B. unten Treppe, Wohnzimmer, Flur, Schlafzimmer, Küche, Bad,
oben Bad, oben Flur, oben Wohnzimmer, oben Schlafzimmer, Teppich
und da kann man hier im, man kann übrigens manuell kontrollen,
man kann ihn glaube ich sogar mittlerweile mit Controller kontrollen.
Du könntest ein Video machen, wie man den flasht, habe ich auf dem Channel als Highlight hochgeladen, musst du mal gucken.
Letzter Highlight-Video ist das Stream, wo ich das geflasht habe.
Nennt sich Leader-Sensor, nee Leader-Sensor ist kein Laser, oder?
Ist Leader-Sensor nicht die Radar-Geschichte gewesen?
Der hat zumindest mit Laser oben drauf.
Und ist halt super einfach zu bedienen, also auch die übelsten Noobs können das bedienen.
Das Ding hat glaube ich eine Zeit von bis zu 3 Stunden, wo es fährt,
hat einen relativ hohen, relativ hohen, relativ großen Tank.
Dazu kommt, dass man theoretisch auch Boden wischen kann, benutze ich aber nicht, finde ich unsinnig.
Und ist halt wirklich praktisch, du kannst sagen, also wenn du fein drückst
und man das deutsche Sprachpaket installiert hat, sagt er, hallo, hier bin ich,
in einer total beknackten Sprache, man müsste da mal das Weep-Sound-Paket dafür entwerfen.
Er macht dann Aja-Jaa, wenn du ihn suchst.
Du kannst hier einstellen, was er machen soll, also wie brutal er zu Werke geht.
Du kannst einstellen...
Okay.
Oh, habe ich ihn jetzt angeschaltet gerade?
Okay, was auch immer.
Man kann ihn quasi los schicken, wo er hinfahren soll.
Man fährt dann hin, macht sauber und fährt selbstständig zum Dock wieder zurück.
Das ist halt wirklich cool.
Und in den Settings, was auch noch nice ist, der hat einen...
Also man kann auch virtuelle Walls aufstellen, dass er in manche Bereiche nicht hinfährt.
Also wenn man zum Beispiel nicht will, dass er beim Katzenklo vorbeifährt und direkt voll ist,
kann man viel einstellen.
Also das ist nicht die offizielle Firmware wohlgemerkt, das ist eine Open Source Firmware von GitHub
auf dem Staubsauger drauf.
Und die inoffizielle Firmware ist mittlerweile besser als die offizielle Firmware.
So, und Carpet Mode kann man einstellen, wenn er den Teppich erkennt.
Das macht er wahrscheinlich je nachdem, wie schwer er rollt.
Teppich ist ja dick, dann rollt er schwerer.
Kann man einstellen, wie er hochdreht.
Und seitdem ist es mega nice im Wohnzimmer drüben.
Die Katze rollt sich halt gerne auf den Teppichraum und alles.
Blockwatcher, das haben wir uns schon mal überlegt.
Ob wir nicht einen Stream machen, so aus Spaß.
Twitch Plays Cleaning Apartment.
Was, wenn er durch Katzenkacke fährt? Verschmiert er das dann in der Wohnung?
Ja, wenn es ein Riesener offen ist, ja.
Ach da, der Katze hat aber noch nirgendswo hingekackt.
Außerdem fährt er nicht einfach random.
Das kann man übrigens auch machen.
Man kann einstellen, dass der zu bestimmten Zeiten fährt und sowas.
Ich lasse ihn aber immer gezielt in den Zimmer fahren, ja.
Also wenn ich sage, ok, jetzt ist Wohnzimmer, Wohnzimmer mit Teppich dran.
Wasche die Tür auf, gucke einmal rein und lasse ihn dann da hinfahren.
Ja, und das Coole daran ist, seitdem ich hier im Wohnzimmer, also hier in der Mitte ist ein Teppich.
Nachdem ich ihn habe und das Ding ordentlich hoch dreht im Vergleich zu meinem anderen, den ich habe,
sind da total wenig Katzenhaare und alles ist sehr sauber auf dem Teppich.
Und ich bin ja jemand, ich kann Hausarbeit überhaupt nicht ab.
Deswegen sauge ich jetzt bloß noch alle Schaltjahre mal,
seitdem ich die ganzen Staubsauger Robot Torts am Start habe.
Also kann ich, kann ich nur empfehlen das Ding.
Was sagt Katz FPS zu dem Robot? Die guckt immer ein bisschen kritisch,
aber die hat da, Chico hat da wenig Probleme mit dem Staubsauger.
Ja, und was an dem, was an dem Staubsauger Robot auch nice ist,
dadurch, dass er diesen Scanner oben hat, wo er den Raum abtastet, fährt er halt auch gezielt.
Der fährt einfach zigzag, nicht zigzag, der fährt einfach Linien in den Raum ab
und ist ziemlich schnell mit dem Zimmer fertig.
Kann man das Flashen und Ruten rückgängig machen?
Ja, kann man glaube ich, kann man, kann man ziemlich sicher, will ich aber nicht.
At all fragt der Choke Gaming Offee.
At all, die helfen können. Ich kenne mich im Serverbereich nicht aus.
Was für Hardware ist empfehlenswert, wenn man lediglich einen File und einen Plex Media Server betreiben möchte?
File Server ist, kann ich dir einfach beantworten,
Plex Server kommt darauf an, ob du Transcoden willst oder nicht und für viele User gleichzeitig.
File Server ist natürlich auch ein bisschen davon abhängig, wie viele User gleichzeitig,
allerdings bei Gigabit Ethernet ist das, was ja Standard ist, ist halt voll, wenn Gigabit voll ist.
File Server ist easy, da brauchst du nichts Großartiges für,
es sei denn du möchtest irgendwie ZFS, Deduplication, Encryption mit Kompression und Geduld,
aber willst du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Plex ist schwer zu beantworten.
Knerbeer, Sub ist in acht Tagen zu Ende.
Würde ich sagen, zweiter Monat.
The Legion, zwei Monate, huge, danke schön.
Staubsaugerhype, rare parrot.
Dann kriegst du für deinen Subscriber Emote, den hier.
Sogar den hier.
Huge.
Manchmal verdröge ich mich irgendwie.
Okay, wir haben schon eins machen, nur 15.
Es kann übrigens sein, dass ich morgen schon ein bisschen früher anfangen kann zu streamen,
weil ich ja morgen Homeoffice und gehe zum Doktor, weil mir schon seit eineinhalb Wochen der Hals übelst weh tut.
Ist irgendwie ganz merkwürdig, Hals weh.
Also nicht da, wo man normalerweise Hals weh hat, wenn man, wenn man,
und hat auch damit nichts zu tun, ja, nur mal so, um mir irgendwelche Sachen wieder vorzubeugen.
Keine Ahnung.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass der mich morgen krank schreibt und sagt, hier ausruhen,
dann kann ich morgen ein bisschen früher streamen schon.
Und wenn nicht, mache ich Homeoffice und bin früher wieder daheim.
Also instantly daheim, wenn ich fertig bin.
Max macht bitte nie wieder den blinkenden Vogel am Ende vom Wit.
Hab davon einen epileptischen, einen halben epileptischen Anfall bekommen.
Ganz bestimmt.
Das ist doch G-Bait.
Kann man nicht vorstellen, dass davon, dass man davon einen Anfall kriegt.
Oder?
Ich mein, ich will jetzt keinem zu nahe treten irgendwie.
Also ich kenn mich damit nicht aus.
Also solltest du das wirklich ernst meinen?
Ja, der Boss ist back.
War nachts mit Handy im Zimmer auf jeden Fall hart.
Okay.
Und der geht oder was?
Also jetzt ist nicht wild oder wie?
Aber was ist mit dem hier?
Was ist mit dem grünen?
Was mit dem grünen Papagei?
Ich find ihn grad nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Hier der da, was mit dem?
War nur auf Choke-Basis, dachte ich mir.
Aber man weiß ja nie, ich kenn mich mit sowas nicht aus.
Ich mein, dass irgendwelche Leute Anfälle kriegen, will ich ja wirklich nicht.
G-Baited, ist das so G-Bait?
Ja, Matt, das kann ich verstehen, dass der Vogel anstrengend ist.
Mentos BFH.
Seht ihr das richtig, dass BFH für Battlefield Hardline steht?
Aber danke für den Twitch Prime Sub.
Battlefield Heroes, ja das könnte natürlich auch sein.
Lieber Battlefield Heroes als Battlefield Hardline.
Obei, nee, Moment, ich bring das durch.
War Heroes nicht der Comic-Look-Free-to-Play?
Weil so extrem scheiße war Hardline gar nicht.
The Heroes, okay.
Speedrun-Video, ja ich brauch erst mal einen, mit dem ich ein Speedrun-Video machen kann.
Die mal einfach kurz aufschalten.
Ja, es kann durchaus sein, dass Battlefield Hardline geschadet hat.
Ja, ja, könnte sein.
Also Battlefield 4 kannst du auf jeden Fall noch spielen.
Battlefield 4 hat ziemlich viele Spieler.
Schau mal, Battlefield 4 hat auf dem PC 10.000, jetzt pass mal auf.
Battlefield 4 hat fast ähnlich viele wie Battlefield 1.
Und über alle Plattformen zusammen hat Battlefield 4, würde ich sagen, fast mehr.
Leider, Leute, leider gibt es keine Battlefield...
Da gehen wir nicht drauf.
Da gehen wir nicht drauf, auf diese Seite.
Soll ich noch mal einen Tick von mir zeigen?
Jedes Mal, wenn ich auf so eine Chibay-Seite gekommen bin, mach ich immer erst den Prozess-Explorer auf.
Und gucke, ob ich mir nicht irgendein Virus eingefangen hab.
Das ist auch so ein Tick, den ich hab.
Immer wenn ich auf so eine Chibay-Seite unter Windows gelandet bin, man weiß ja nie, weil es Windows ist.
Ich bin nicht auf der Seite gelandet, es kann nichts passiert sein.
Mach ich immer Prozess-Explorer auf und gucke, ob irgendwelche verdächtigen Aktivitäten auf dem Rechner laufen.
Und aktuell sehe ich keine verdächtigen Aktivitäten außer irgendwelche Microsoft-Shit da im Hintergrund läuft.
Ach ja, und was auch übelst lächerlich ist, dass dieses komische Corsair-Software fürs Nichtstun permanent CPU-Last verbraucht.
Stubi Die verschenkt ein Stufe-1-Abo an die Community, und zwar das erste Geschenk auf diesem Kanal, und zwar an Wambo333.
Dankeschön, Subscriber.
Bezüglich Windows-Hintergrund-Prozesse. Nee, ich schraub da nichts dran rum. Es ist ja nicht so, als würde es mein Rechner irgendwie großartig langsamer machen.
Ich weiß, dass der Prozess-Explorer Virus total sammeln kann.
Was hältst du denn von Cyberpunk? Das ist eine interessante Frage, das hatten wir schon ein paar Mal.
Was hältst du denn von Cyberpunk? Das ist eine interessante Frage, das hatten wir schon ein paar Mal. Freust du dich schon auf den nächsten Teil?
Kommt doch jetzt der erste Teil des Cyberpunk raus. Moment, what? Gibt's schon Cyberpunk 2078? Ich wäre ja eigentlich eher gewesen für Cyberpunk 2069.
Hast du CoD eigentlich schon vorbestellt? Nein. Kein CoD vorbestellt. Ich stelle nichts mehr vor. Die Ausnahme habe ich vorhin am Anfang erzählt, aber...
Auf YouTube schreibt gerade einer, er hat den Stream verpasst. Er kann nicht geguckt haben, weil der Stream ist noch on.
Das letzte Metro gespielt? Nein, noch nicht. Ich habe es schon oft gesagt, ich bin kein Fan von Open-World-Spielen.
Cyberpunk ist so eine Sache. Witcher hat es geschafft, durch eine ordentliche rote Linie und eine gute Hauptquest, hat dafür gesorgt, dass man eben auch in der Open-World einen faden hat.
Aber reine Open-World-Sandbox-Spiele sind halt echt nicht mein Fall. Deswegen mag ich auch GTA Online und so. Ich glaube, das CD Projekt das eigentlich kann.
Dazu kommt noch bei Cyberpunk, dass ich das Setting an sich nicht mag. Das sind schon zwei Sachen, die mir an dem Spiel nicht gefallen. Sowohl das Setting ist nicht wirklich meins, also quasi dieser düstere Zukunftsstelz, und dass ich halt mit Open-World auch nicht so viel anfangen kann.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt niemand, der super gehypt ist auf Cyberpunk. Aber ich bin gespannt, was rauskommt. Und ich gehe davon aus, dass GTA 5 mache ich auch nicht.
Gta mache ich auch nicht. Hast du die Stalker-Reihe gespielt? Ja. Soll da nicht jetzt demnächst irgendwas neues kommen?
Hast du Geburtstag? Wenn ja, dann Kratz. Five Head Wine.
Dann kommt die neue Gartentour. Es wird Zeit für einen im Grashalm Revealed. Es hat sich nichts getan im Garten. Dass man alle zusammen ein eigenes Soundpack für den Staubsauger-Roboter erstellt. Das war eine lustige Idee, ja.
Nee, WoW fange ich nicht an. Wenn ich WoW anfangen würde, dann würde ich keine Videos mehr machen, keinen Stream mehr machen und nichts.
Dann würde ich nichts mehr machen.
Ist dein Chrome-Broser auch ein bisschen langsamer mit Dark oder bild ich mir das nicht, dass ich es gemerkt hätte?
Weep Shit. Ja, das ist nur, um meine Mods zu erfreuen. Und die ganzen restlichen Weeps hier, da haben wir ja jede Menge.
Die haben mich auch dazu überredet, so viele Weep-Emotes bei Bella Twitch TV einzufügen. Aber weißt du, ich wäre selbst auf die Idee gekommen, irgendwelche Upleg-Emotes einzubauen.
Aber ich will ja, dass wir sind ja hier inclusive. Also wenn Weeps Weeps Emote wollen, dann kriegen wir Weeps Weeps Emote.
Kein Problem, solange das Setout läuft, ist mir das egal. Dann kriegt jeder seine Emotes, die er haben will.
100 Twitch Prime, dankeschön, nice. Als was arbeitest du eigentlich? Zockst du eigentlich noch zwischendurch mit dem Friseur? Der Friseur spielt hauptsächlich Black Desert.
Der spielt sogar mittlerweile ab und zu mit meinem Account. Wahrscheinlich habe ich schon das übertriebenste OP-Gear mittlerweile wieder. Aber BDO ist nichts, was mich jetzt so bei der Laune gehalten hat.
Wies du Bücher? Nö. Ich höre Bücher manchmal. Das Einzige, was ich an Büchern lese, sind Technikgeschichten. Irgendwelche Programmier-Sachen oder so.
Der Fabian spielt immer noch BDO, klar. Was denkst du von Kotlin als Einstieg zur App-Programmierung? Zu Java-Sachen darfst du mich nichts fragen.
Ich habe nur gehört von ein paar Java-Entwicklern bei uns auf der Arbeit, dass sie froh wären mit Kotlin arbeiten zu können, als wenn sie das benutzen könnten anstatt ihr normales Java-Zeug.
Findest du eigentlich spontaner Black? Guckt das eigentlich zu wenig, dass ich da jetzt irgendwie eine großartige Beinung mir bilden könnte? Keine Ahnung. Ist nicht mein Content.
Ich kann auch zu den ganzen anderen Leuten auf YouTube mittlerweile wenig sagen. Ich habe zum Beispiel keine Ahnung, was macht der Muscle so zum Beispiel? Was macht der Muscle so zum Beispiel?
Das Skorpion oder hier, wie heißt der andere? Sein Kumpel da. Ich weiß gar nicht, was die alle machen. Ich gucke das nicht mehr. Ich habe das voll aus den Augen verloren.
Das liegt aber einfach daran, dass es kein Content für mich ist in dem Sinn. Die machen kein Content für Leute, die 35 sind.
Oder Inscope. Inscope gucke ich auch nicht. Ich halte den Nico für den original Lifestyle-Channel auf YouTube, den wir in Deutschland haben. Der war quasi die Inspiration für viele.
Und der Nico an sich ist auch ein wirklich, zumindest früher, sehr netter Kerl gewesen. Wie es jetzt ist, weiß ich nicht. Die Leute ändern sich ja mit der Zeit auch. Aber verfolge ich auch alles nicht.
Ich kann dazu ehrlich gesagt nichts sagen. Deskabasa hat eine 200k Nachzahlung ans Finanzamt offen. Wenn einer eine 200k Nachzahlung ans Finanzamt offen hat, kann man von ausgehen, dass er an sich nicht gerade am Hungertuch nagt, weil irgendwo müssen die 200k herkommen, die man nachzahlen muss.
Erlebt ihr dort Tricks eigentlich noch? Kein Schimmer. Halt ich auch nie wirklich Kontakt, großartig.
Kennst du gute Videos oder Beiträge, wo erklärt wird, wie man was für den Raspberry Pi programmiert? Du programmierst ja nicht wirklich was für den Raspberry Pi, sondern du nimmst eine Programmiersprache und programmierst da drin was und kannst auf den Raspberry Pi laufen lassen.
Es sei denn, du meinst, wie du irgendwelche Pins und sowas vom Raspberry Pi ansteuerst.
Niko stimmt auch bei Twitch. Ja, hab ich gesehen. Wird wieder Zeit in die Szene einzusteigen? Es gibt die Szene doch gar nicht mehr. Guck mal, die machen jetzt alle Fitnessvideos oder Lifestyle-Gedöns oder Bombenpranks oder was? Keine Ahnung. Das ist bestimmt kein Content, wo ich irgendwie einsteigen könnte, noch einsteigen möchte.
Das wird zu blöd. Wie gesagt, mit 35 bin ich auch nicht derjenige, wo irgendjemand das krasse Lifestyle-Video sehen will. Was soll ich da machen?
Frankfurt City, Lifestyle, Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store, zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor. Was soll ich machen? Collaboration mit Haftbefehl im Frankfurter Ghetto. Was für ein Auto fährst du, hauptsächlich keins?
Iska wurde von seiner Schwester abgezogen. Ach, ich würd nicht alles glauben, was auf YouTube so erzählt wird. Da ist so viel Bullshit im Umlauf.
Marcel macht Werbung für Porno-Seiten. Na ja, soll er doch. Manch einer spielt Fappy Bird und manch einer macht Werbung für Porno-Seiten.
Nie Steuern überwiesen. Na ja, gut. Also wer so viel verdient und nie Steuern überweist, der ist das Gegenteil von so.
Also ist das erste, was ich gemacht hab, als ich angefangen hab mit YouTube bisschen Kohle zu verdienen, den Kram angemeldet und Steuern bezahlt, weil ich keinen Bock auf so Kack habe, dass sowas passiert.
Die Montana Black ist nicht 35 oder ist der Top 10 oder S30? Dass es die Szenen nicht mehr gibt, liegt auch daran, dass alle kurz scheiß werden.
Die Szenen an sich, es gibt schon noch relativ viele Leute, die Call of Duty Content machen. Haptic Rush gibt es noch. Fanto macht noch Call of Duty Videos. Es gibt schon noch ein paar, es ist ja nicht, dass es komplett weg wäre.
Was hat er selbst erzählt? Ja selbst, wenn jemand was, als müsste man was drauf geben, nur weil einer auf YouTube irgendwas erzählt.
Wie viel Blödsinn auf YouTube erzählt wird. Auch wenn er selbst erzählt ist, frage würde ich, ob ich das alles so glauben würde.
KS Freak und Crappy What Else sind auch beide Insolent. Wer war das nochmal? Ach, hat sich der Friseur nicht mal auf der Gamescom mit dem KS Freak in den Haaren vor irgendwie acht Jahren oder so?
Das Einzige, wo ich mich da irgendwie noch dran erinnern kann.
Wie lange fährst du mit der Bahn zur Arbeit? Meinst du von Tür zu Tür oder Fahrzeitbahn?
Schau dir doch mal das neue Inscope Video an. Ich weiß, was der Nico für Videos macht. Ich weiß aber auch, dass das nicht Content für mich ist.
Dass das nicht Content ist, der mich anspricht. Du hältst aber echt gut an der 240 sogar, nice. Heute ist viel, finde ich cool, wie viele Leute von YouTube da sind.
Was sagst du dazu, dass PewDiePie die 100 Millionen geknackt hat? Ich finde es schade, dass er das T-Series ihn überholt hat.
Was interessieren mich Bollywood-Musikvideos? PewDiePie ist mal ganz ehrlich, ich fand den Typ früher übelst kacke.
Ich hätte mir den nie anguckt, aber ich habe mir vor einer Weile mal ein paar Videos von ihm angeguckt. Der ist gar nicht blöd.
So dämlich manche Videos auf den ersten Blick wirken. Du merkst, dass der Typ nicht blöd ist.
Viele Sachen sind auch wirklich lustig, ohne dass er lacht dabei. Den kann ich mir tatsächlich angucken.
Gibt es jetzt Emotes? Ja, gibt es jetzt Emotes. Oh, ich habe uns abverpasst. Meister Makrele, habe ich noch mehr verpasst? Meister Makrele ist am Start. Und wen haben wir noch?
Meister Makrele, danke schön. Für jede Minute, wo ich vergessen habe es vorzulesen. Wobei nicht so lange warst du dann auch wieder nicht her.
Das ist mir egal. Die AdSense-Verdienste sind immer ziemlich egal. Das, womit Kohle verdient wird, sind die zusätzlichen Deals.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal helfen, dass ich die Motivation behalte, weil die ersten 14 Tage, wenn man wieder neu auf YouTube anfängt, das sind die schwierigsten.
Sowohl YouTube-Algorithmus technisch, als Subscriber, weil die erstmal aufgeräumt wird und das Algorithmus wieder in Schwung kommt, und vor allem motivationsmäßig. Da brauche ich hier Energie.
Seipai kann ich nichts zu sagen. Ich habe ihn mal 5 Sekunden auf der Gamescom getroffen. Ich kann zu der Person nichts sagen. Aber wenn jemand so viele Leute anspricht, muss ja zumindest der Content-Gaming-Technik ganz gut sein.
Das ist themenbezogener Call of Duty-Kram. Unabhängig davon, ob man ihn selbst toll findet oder nicht. Aber es scheint die Gaming-Komponente schon mal nicht verkehrt zu sein.
Was sagt ihr eigentlich zu den neuen E-Modes? Das einzige E-Mode, das ich selbst gemacht habe, ist WubCup. WubS ist von jemandem auf dem Discord. WubLul habe ich von FFZ geklaut und leicht abgeändert. Und WubOld auch.
Anzeige ist raus direkt. Und dazu, Sebaru, du hast Recht. Alter, was ist mit dem Chat los? Der Chat ist richtig nice. Wir mussten heute noch nicht einen bannen oder irgendwie Timeouten oder sonst was.
PewDiePie ist auch feierabend, ich weiß. Wen ich überhaupt nicht mag, übrigens sage ich für die ganzen Subs, ich bin im Chat noch nicht so weit, ich gucke gleich.
Wen ich oder was ich überhaupt nicht mag, sind so diese, wie soll ich das am besten nennen, so diese Let's-Player-Persönlichkeiten, die alles mögen.
Ich kann das schwierig beschreiben. Nicht PewDiePie, der mag nicht alles. So die Let's-Play-Typen, die schwierig zu beschreiben. Haben wir in Deutschland auch ein paar.
Aber es gibt so Let's-Play-Persönlichkeiten, das ist für mich der Inbegriff von, wie könnte man dazu sagen, von so gespielt einfach nur.
Einfach nur so gespielt. Da gibt es international richtig viele von. Das kann ich mir nicht angucken, das halte ich nicht aus.
Wen ich auch absolut nicht mag, ist Alexibexy. Ich weiß nicht, ich kenne den Typ nicht, aber irgendwie finde ich die Videos übelst crap.
Kommt eigentlich noch ein Battlefield-3-Guide mit Willi-Pete-Cast. Boah ey, ich habe von Felix ewig nichts mehr gehört. Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht irgendwann mal, weiß ich. Laluko1 abonniert mit Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, nice.
Hast du noch Kontakte zu GermanLPK? Nein. Friseur? Ja. Kaboom. Sehr, sehr unregelmäßig, selten. Willi-Pete-Cast zu Battlefield 1 haben wir mal 2-3 Nachrichten, also auch nicht.
Max sitzt in der Bahn und hört die 50 PS. Ich höre nicht die 50 PS, ich sehe die 500 FPS. Monka-Eye.
Was? Null Views-Gefühl? Was? Ein paar Gaming-Booster kaufen. Habe ich letztens beim Lost gesehen, den World Wide First Gaming-Prain-Booster oder irgendwie sowas.
Habe ich auch in der Lost da für Werbung gemacht. Dann muss das auch was taugen. Nee, der wird wahrscheinlich genauso Sellout machen wie ich früher bei G2A hole.
Das Ratchet hat 5 Abos verschenkt, Stufe 1. Und zwar an Centillion, TimoGL, SalamiPrince. Den Name kann man irgendwie auch minimal falsch verstehen, SalamiPrince.
An den Stelzo und an Mirikari. Dankeschön für die ganzen Abos. Und willkommen an alle die, die die Abos gespendet bekommen haben. Sehr nice, Dankeschön.
Pock. Alter. Huge. Massive. Bleib bei deiner Motivation. Ich sag doch, ich brauch Energy vom Chat.
Gift-Energy. Muss jetzt in jedem Stream Energy gegift kriegen. Ich rede via das Twitch Zeug, oder? Versteht kein Mensch was ich eigentlich von mir gebe.
Flame Haste. Nee, sogar den haben wir nicht gebannt. Ach, das ist lustig. Vom Noob-Special-Video auf den Stream gekommen. Wollt mal schauen, ob du da bist. Ja, ich bin doch immer noch da.
Gronkh. Nee, Gronkh finde ich gut. Gronkh guck ich persönlich nicht, weil die Spiele mich nicht ansprechen und Gronkh auch so ultra lahm bei allen Games ist irgendwie.
Aber Gronkh meine ich damit überhaupt nicht. Gronkh ist keiner der alles gut findet. Ich erinnere mich auch daran, dass er irgendwann mal seinen SimCity Let's Play Rage quittet hat, weil das Spiel so gesackt hat.
So Leute wie Gronkh meine ich nicht. Wen gibt's denn da so ultra happy Let's Play Typen? Wie heißt der Jacksepticeye oder irgendwie sowas? Das kann ich mir alles nicht angucken.
Komm, One vs. One Quickscope. Aber nur auf Rust. Concraft, der hat das auch jemanden, den kann ich mir halt geben.
Wenn ich übrigens sage, ich kann es mir nicht geben, heißt das genau das, ich kann es mir nicht geben. Das heißt nicht, dass das irgendwie vom Typen Spaß sein muss oder sonst was. Einfach nur, dass ich es mir nicht geben kann.
Falls jetzt wieder irgendjemand das rumklippt und irgendwie Beef anfangen will oder so. Balluten kenne ich nicht. Also sag mir vom Namen, das habe ich noch nie geguckt.
Max, wenn du willst, ich bin als Manager noch frei, kannst mich easy buchen, bekommst gute Placements. Placements, was? In Overwatch oder wie? Ach werbe Placements. Ja easy, auf geht's.
Machen wir, würde ich sagen, 98-2 Split.
Die ganzen deutschen Minecraft-Hipster-YouTubers kenne ich keinen von. Gibt es den Dana eigentlich noch? Der Dana ist jetzt Rennfahrer oder sowas, ne? Verfolge ich nicht, aber wer auch ganz komisch geworden ist irgendwie ist Unge.
Der React als Unge ist irgendwie das geworden, was er selbst früher nicht gemacht hat, habe ich den Eindruck. Ich will einfach nur Games spielen und irgendwie Dinge machen zu Reaction-Content.
Das hat jeder so seinen Geschmack, ja? Du sagst im Noob-Special, was von Programmieren arbeitest du in dem Feld? Studiere auch gerade Informatik. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf, da gibt es eine Erklärung zu, was ich gerade auf der Arbeit mache.
Kommt dein erster Gangster-Rap-Track? Na ich mach keinen Gangster-Rap, ich hab gedacht ich revolutioniere das Ganze ein bisschen, ich mach Informatiker-Rap. Quasi sowas, ich hab's ja vorfeld schon gesagt, so in der Richtung wie, dein Vater ist blau wie das Discord-Logo. Oder?
Was könnte man da noch machen? Ich bin so unkreativ sowas spontan zu machen. Die Bitches stehen an der Tür, wie bei Philipp Amthor. Nee, das ergibt keinen Sinn, aber habt ihr's verstanden? Witz. Übelst übelst nice. Tür und Amthor. Übelst übelst cringe-joke, ich weiß. Das gibt Informatiker-Rap, machen wir dann.
Wo bestellst du deinen China-Kram immer? AliExpress, Banggood, eigentlich die zwei hauptsächlich. Pains-Champ, ja das tut weh, ich weiß. Oh fuck, ich komm im Chat nicht hinterher Leute. Mach mal nicht so schnell.
Dankeschön für die Subs. Dom16Eevils, Evil, 2222IL, ich hoff mal, das stimmt, xRagnarok, xRagnasonX, Dankeschön an alle drei für die Subs.
Wo hast du die Sounds für Soundbord her? Das haben wir selbst programmiert. Onstream sogar. General Slane, auch danke für den Sub. Huge Subscriber. Was denn heut los? Ist der Wahnsinns, wenn ich weiter so einen krassen Sellout mach hier auf dem Stream und öfters mal auf YouTube poste. Da gibt's ja hier...
Wo ist der Staubsauger? Oh das hatten wir schon. Staubsauger haben wir uns heute schon angekockt. Adopted Anton, abonniert Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Wie viele Subs bist du mittlerweile? Ich guck mal nach. Soll ich mal nachgucken? Nein, ich hab nicht gefragt. Sonst kollt der Chat noch schneller. Sollte man deiner Meinung nach um Fullstack WebDeveloper zu werden studiert haben? Nö.
Otzimdk, Otzimdk, hoff da stimmt, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, nice.
PC Master Race, Subscriber. Take my Energy Grip, das ist falsche Copypasta.
Wieso kann ich die animierten Bilder nicht im Chat sehen? Du musst das in deinem Better Twitch TV oder FrankerFaces Chat einschalten, dass du animierte Emotes siehst.
Lohnt sich ein 4K Bildschirm? Für Spiele nicht, finde ich. 240Hz größer 4K für Games. Fürs Arbeiten schon. Ich warte ja noch auf einen passenden Bildschirm für mich.
So, ich muss gerade mal den Chat überscrollen, sonst kann ich mal wieder runterkommen.
Willst du sustain? Nein, wie findest du seinen Stream Content? Kenn ich nicht.
Max geht schlafen. Ach, das war die Reaktion auf meinen tollen Informatiker Rap Versuch. Am Tor. Ich fand den nicht schlecht.
An der Tür und Philipp am Tor. Ich weiß gar nicht wie man den Typ schreibt, aber man spricht den irgendwie so aus.
Max lacht gerade über 10 Minuten. Ich komm mit dem Chat halt überhaupt nicht hinterher gerade. Slow-Mode Chat? Nee, sowas mach ich nicht. Das mach ich erst bei 300 Zuschauern, bloß wenn weiter so gespamsort wird.
Wenn ihr mit Twitch-Copy-Pasta anfangen könnt ich euch gleich sagen, dann kann ich nix mehr beantworten aus dem Chat, das ist dann halt selber Schuld. Dann könnt ich vielleicht YouTube-Comments wieder beantworten, was ich eigentlich ursprünglich vorhatte.
Der Boss ist back, das ist auch nicht schlecht. Hast du eine extra Tastatur für die ganzen Animationen im Stream? Nee, ich hab nur ein Web-Interface, sieht so aus.
So sieht das aus. Und wenn einer was von Java schreibt, hab ich den hier noch am Start. Halbschatten, abonniere Twitch Prime, ich muss mal gucken ob ich nix vergessen hab in der Zwischenzeit.
Ein Dankeschön, Halbschatten. Pog. Nein, falsch. Kommt Staubsaugerstuff noch auf? Klar, ich probier das. Ich versuch da Minecraft drauf zum Laufen zu kriegen. Und wenn Minecraft nicht funktioniert, wovon ich mal ehrlich gesagt ausgehe, versuch ich zumindest einen Minecraft-Server drauf laufen zu lassen um mich drauf zu connecten.
Ist, ich mein, Minecraft-Server ist für den Staubsauger schon krass genug, oder?
Hast du Vikings geschaut? Ja, die erste 2 Staffeln oder so. Danach hat's mir nicht mehr gefallen.
So, ich bin mit dem Chat wieder durch, ich hab's geschafft. Ich bin mit dem Chat. Wie viel RAM hat der Staubsauger? Gute Frage, wie viel RAM hat der Staubsauger? Gucken wir doch mal nach, wie viel RAM der Staubsauger hat.
Ich glaub 512 MB RAM hat der Staubsauger. Also Leute, nur mal angemerkt, ich verbinde mich gerade per SSH auf meinen Staubsauger. Muss sein. Staubsauger. Wie sagt man heute? Auf meinen Nacken.
Ja, 512 MB RAM. Ganz normal kennt man. Also 512 MB haben wir. Auf dem Staubsauger läuft aktuell gerade ein Ubuntu 14.04 LTS. Und ich könnte auch ohne Probleme...
Warte mal, ich probier mal was. Absearch Minecraft. Gibt's das vielleicht sogar schon im Repo drin? Nee, gibt's. Dann nicht. Also Staubsauger hat 512 MB. Aktuell frei.
Also für einen Java-Minecraft-Server reicht der RAM nicht. Und der Festplattenspeicher reicht. Na doch, doch. Vielleicht brauch ich gar keinen USB-Stick. Ich brauch irgendeinen, es gibt bestimmt irgendeinen Minimal-C-Minecraft-Server, der nix kann, aber zumindest reicht für Connecten.
Den werd ich da drauf installieren und dann spielen wir Minecraft auf dem Staubsauger. Was muss man nehmen auf solche Ideen zu kommen? Da kommt das eine zum anderen.
C-Minecraft-Server. Warum sollst du in C keinen Minecraft-Server programmieren können? Das ist Netzwerkzeug. Für einen Minecraft-Server ist wichtig, was der Server sendet und empfängt. Ob in welcher Programmiersprache der Minecraft-Server geschrieben wird, ist vollkommen wurscht.
Der Minecraft-Server kann auch in Fortran programmiert sein, also vollkommen egal. Minetest, was ist denn Minetest? Aha. Ach, gibt's schon für Linux, ok. Also ich brauch's halt für ARM, weil CPU, wir können doch mal gucken, was für eine CPU im Staubsauger drin ist.
Aber Minecraft ist ja, ist doch egal ob Minecraft, Java ist, der Client mag Java sein, aber die Sachen, die er zum Server hin und zurück schickt, vollkommen egal, in welcher Sprache der Server selbst ist.
Es gibt Minecraft-Server in Go, es gibt Minecraft-Server in C und es gibt Minecraft-Server auch in Java. Aber warte mal, wir gucken mal, was da, ach warte, was guck ich denn da, ich bin auch falsch.
Also welche CPU ist im Staubsauger drinnen? Ein Vierkern ARM 7, ja ARMv7 gibt's garantiert im Minecraft-Server schon fertig kompiliert, weil Minecraft auf, Minecraft-Server auf dem Staubsauger-Roboter kompilieren kann man glaube ich vergessen.
Ich will auch ehrlich gesagt keinen Compiler installieren auf dem Staubsauger. Ich weiß, klingt abgedreht, aber ist halt so. Es ist ein Vierkern ARMv7 CPU im Staubsauger drin.
Das sollte für den billig Minecraft-Server schon reichen. Ich find's übrigens, ich find's übrigens geil, dass ein Staubsauger den Quad-Core mittlerweile drin hat.
Und eigentlich musst du auch Doom auf den Staubsauger, Doom läuft auf allem. Doom läuft auf allem. Das ist der S50 Press, ja.
Ne, Sebaro, ich hab heut morgen schon nachgeguckt. Es gibt Minecraft-Server auch in Go und in C. Sogar schon vorgefertigt für ARM.
Das hätte dir mal wer vor 10 Jahren sagen müssen, dass du mal Minecraft-Server auf deinem Vierkern Staubsauger-Roboter installieren willst. Ja, da hätt ich mir vor 4 Jahren gedacht, ich hab's ja nämlich alle.
Aber das Internet of Shits ist überall. Gibt auch die eine, die vom Kühlschrank aus twittert mittlerweile.
Ok Leute, ihr kennt's, 22 Uhr. Da muss ich meistens pennen. Und das ist auch heute der Fall.
Ich guck jetzt mal kurz, ob's jemand gibt, den ich hosten kann. Wie hat euch der Stream gefallen heute? Es war heute ziemlich sehr, sehr viel Gelaber. Wir haben nicht wirklich was gemacht.
Wollen wir ab und zu mal solche YouTube-Comments machen? Ich glaub, das ist ne gute Idee.
Leider glaub ich keiner on, den ich hosten konnte. Den haben wir dann hier. Den Cyrus könnte man hosten. WoW Classic ist zwar nicht meins. Was ein sehr netter Dude.
Oder wir hosten einfach gar keinen. Warum hab ich kein Emote von meinem Namen? Hast du bei mir? Bei mir hast du einen Keks vom Name. Gehst du gerade off? Ja, in ein paar Minuten.
Ich soll niemand hosten. Ja, könnt ihr Cyrus hosten. Die Sache ist die, ist es WoW Classic. Und ich weiß nicht, inwieweit euch WoW Classic interessiert. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ihr noch spielt. Und zuweil ich auch kein WoW Classic gucke.
Was hältst du von der Unity-Media-Übernahme von Vodafone? Gutes Thema. Ich sag's noch einmal. Ich hab's am Anfang gesagt, da waren noch nicht so viele da.
Wenn ihr Themenvorschläge habt, wo man auch gut ein Video draus machen könnte, wie zum Beispiel die Unity-Media-Übernahme von Vodafone. Das könnt ihr bestimmt ganz gut in ein Video einbauen.
Und ihr Discord habt, macht mal Ausrufezeichen Discord. Wir haben einen Discord-Server und da gibt es auch einen, ich zeig's mal. Da haben wir extra einen Channel für Themenvorschläge.
Und umso mehr Themen, ich hab, ich mein, ich hab schon mittlerweile jetzt wieder ne gute Liste an Themen, ja. Aber umso mehr Themenvorschläge ich hab, umso besser. Machst du mal wieder IT-Müten? Ja, mach ich.
Oh, ich hätt noch, Leute, weil ich hier grad Axel Voss, Axel Voss lese, ich hätt noch einen krassen, äh, ja, Rap, äh, ähm, wie nennt man das überhaupt? Line.
Ja, man könnte irgendwie sowas machen, wie, ähm, seine Bitches haben mehr Haare unter den Achseln, wie Axel Voss. Oh, ist das schlecht, das ist übelst Painchamp, Alter, das ist übelst, das ist Grinch hoch 10.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ey, die meisten Texte, die ich mir da durchlese, die sind so dermaßen schlecht, da wär ich auch drauf gekommen.
Haftbefehl ist immer noch, Haftbefehl Beste. Die Delivery ist auch wichtig, ja, das kann ich nicht. Haftbefehl Beste. Der gibt sich jetzt gar keine Mühe, das irgendwie, ähm, ausgefallen zu machen.
Der sagt das einfach ohne irgendwas. Wolltest du dich am Ende nicht noch? Hab ich ja mittlerweile schon gemacht. Hab ich ja schon, hab ich ja schon, Thema hab ich ja schon durch.
Ähm, gut Leute, also, ich seh schon die ersten Leute flüchten, ähm, aber jetzt ist ja auch vorbei. Wie viele Subs hast du nun? Ich habe, ich gucke mal.
216, übelst nice, Dankeschön für alle Leute, die heute gesubbt haben. Richtig, richtig viel, ähm, richtig viel neue Subs, richtig viel neue Zuschauer.
Wie gesagt, ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen. Ähm, 216 Abonnenten, das heißt, wir haben jetzt noch ein neues Emote.
Ich hab jetzt, ich glaube, 14 Emote Slots oder sowas und sagenhafte vier Emotes davon schon verwendet. Was machst du jetzt mit dem Big Twitch Money?
China Kram kaufen? Oder an Leute für Wucherzinsen verleihen?
Im nächstes kaufe ich mir ein neues Klon. Shit, FPS 2. Versteuern? Ja, das mach ich, das mach ich auch, ja.
Twitch Subs verschenken mit, mit, äh, Twitch Money. Hast du feste Zeit zum Streamen oder immer spontan? Meistens ab 18 Uhr, 18 Uhr 30.
Außer, die einzig feste Streamzeit, die ich habe, ist sonntags, sonntags morgens zum Aufwachen.
Das hat eigentlich schon Tradition, dass wir so rum, dass wir so 9 Uhr 30, 10 Uhr rum, 9 bis 10 Uhr anfangen, ein sonntags Aufwachstream zu machen.
Naja, ich bin da mit dem Video, genau. Ok, Leute, ähm, Outro-Musik. Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Stream, wir sehen uns morgen, hoffe ich, spätestens übermorgen bei einem neuen Video. Und jetzt macht's gut, bis denn, CU.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels. Falsches Video.
Falsches Video.